recall that you can click on the
timestamp in the description to skip
this longish introduction
this is a pivotal episode in the toe
series on the phenomenon because it's
akin to a meta episode with the first
half being a talk on the ufo topic and
the second half being a talk on the
types of talks on the ufo topic this
makes it a podcast that though salutary
you rarely hear about thank you to sean
and lou for their candor and
unguardedness this is the third
interview with lou elizondo outmatching
even the previous as his longest
interview ever this time we're joined
with sean cahill lou elizondo is a
former us army counterintelligence
special agent mostly known as the
director of the now defunct atip which
was a program initiated by the defense
intelligence agency in order to study
the uap phenomenon also known as ufos
chief sean cahill served in the united
states navy from 1995 to 2015 with
missions spanning from anti-terrorism to
anti-piracy to interrogations and
investigations he's a co-founder and
strategic advisor at skyfort.org
that is
skyfort.org which is a think tank and
tech incubator working on uap studies
click on the timestamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kurt jaimungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics interested in
explicating the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from mainly a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as understanding the role
consciousness has to fundamental reality
the plan is for this podcast sometime
this year to lead somewhere perhaps even
earlier starting with ideas and gauge
theory which begin in ideas and lead
group theory and build up to the
infinite categorical approaches to
physics like infinite categories and
modal homotopy type theories as well and
even geometric algebra the reason being
that the physical theories of everything
and the language to understand them and
the unification attempts are more
elegantly written and understood from
those perspectives at least to some
people outside of the universities there
are no accessible texts on this
let alone media content so hopefully the
toe podcast will serve as a stanchion
supporting the quest for understanding
the mathematical fundamental principles
if you enjoy witnessing and engaging
with others in real time on the topics
of consciousness psychology physics and
mathematics then check out the
description for a link to the discord
and subreddit there's also a link to the
patreon which is patreon.com
kurtjmungle if you'd like to support
this podcast as support from the patrons
and the sponsors are the only reasons
that i can bring podcasts of this
quality and depth as this is now what
i'm able to do full time thanks to your
support speaking of sponsors there are
three the first sponsor is that ufo
podcast that ufo podcast is one of the
world's premier destinations for
everything related to the subject of
ufos and related phenomena created in
may 2020 by scottish host andy mcgrillen
the show has hosted many of the largest
names in the ufo community including lou
elizondo avilobe and george knapp plus
many many more in addition to interviews
regular co-host dan zetterstrom joins
andy for weekly news breakdowns bringing
you the latest ufo news in a concise and
easy to digest format the discursive
style of dialogue is such that it's both
entertaining and informative in fact dan
and andy are two people i regularly
confer with when i don't understand the
history of some particular ufo-related
event or for general explanations of
what people like lou have said about the
phenomenon they also helped call and
order the list of questions for this
episode so adulation should be directed
toward them the links to that ufo
podcast are in the description or you
can simply search quote unquote that ufo
podcast the second sponsor is ground
news if you're someone like myself who's
ever exposed to the unrelenting
onslaught of digital media you've become
increasingly skeptical of the veracity
of the information you're receiving
particularly with regard to balance and
that's where ground news comes in for
every breaking news story they'll show
you which media outlets are reporting on
the issue and where they fall on the
political spectrum you can instantly
spot media bias discover stories outside
your own perhaps unrecognized echo
chamber and attain some clarity
especially in these chaotic times the
ground news website and app lets you
compare headlines from left center and
right sources simply with a swipe and
their blind spot feed will show you
stories that are not being reported by
one side of the political spectrum
subscribers also gain access to features
like my news bias which lets you track
your reading habits so you can see how
factual your sources are who owns them
and much more ground news isn't better
news it's an improved manner of the
consumption of news download the ground
news app or browser extension to make
sure that you're seeing the full picture
visit www.ground.news
toe to demand more from your news now on
to the third and last sponsor
urgentcare.com urgentcare.com is a
forward-thinking healthcare company that
understands why we all do share the same
biology our personal needs and
requirements are uniquely our own
urgentcare.com has an appreciation and
respect and gratitude for any individual
or entity that seeks to help the human
species without question luella sando
and sean cahill all deserve thanks for
helping humanity answer some of life's
most important and challenging questions
that statement comes from urgent care
themselves and i agree with it visit
urgentcare.com for convenient healthcare
for everyone thank you and enjoy this
lengthy engrossing and revelatory ask me
anything session with luis elisondo and
sean cahill okay it says that we're live
now if you can see this please type into
the chat charizard is not over hyped
charizard is not overhyped
all right there we go
okay thank you sean thank you lou i
appreciate it
and you know me i like to be efficient
and make a great use of our time and the
audiences as well so we'll get straight
to the questions this one is directed to
both of you and we'll start with lou lou
while you're in the government and then
sean while you're in the government have
you ever come across the words element
115 did you see it did you read it did
you ever hear someone allude to it so
first of all kurt um
how you doing you're doing good
good doing great everybody out there in
uh
in the uh social media world thank you
very much for having having me uh and
spending today's afternoon with me
um
don't i mean don't get me wrong i don't
mind kissing on the first date kurt but
uh just wanted to first say
thank you for having us on here and to
your audience for having us
uh two very quick uh today is a bit of a
special day for me my my daughter
uh taylor is getting married uh she's
over in california uh getting married to
uh
her fiance joe and uh he's over in
monterey right now at the defense
language institute uh learning a
language um and serving our country so a
huge shout out if i made to to him thank
you for joe for your service to our
nation uh we are eternally grateful and
uh taylor and joe congratulations
uh congratulations
yep nope nope
i appreciate it uh and kurt uh you're
looking mighty spiffy today so um just
for you man
and sean we break the ice a little bit
um and sean thank you for
for always your your friendship uh and
and you know being being with me um it's
it's profoundly appreciated and then one
last big thanks to all the folks out
there um who continue to to support uh
this effort moving forward um there's a
lot of folks in the uk that are trying
to to do what we've done here uh in the
united states so a big shout out to them
and finally a big shout out to to all of
you in the audience thank you so very
much for being here with us um it is
truly an honor and privilege now now
that we've got that out of the way kurt
let's answer your question about element
115 um no um
there is obviously a lot of discussion
about it in the uh twitterverse and
social media but that was never a part
of the the a-tip portfolio uh doesn't
mean it wasn't part of portfolios
beforehand or perhaps you know some
other efforts uh that were parallel or
tangential to atip but while i was
native element 115 wasn't ever really
part of any type of discussion
sean i never no i never encountered
anything like that i wouldn't have um
even if it were purportedly
anything like what it's supposed to be
i've only heard about it in
zeitgeist of ufology from the same
sources
do you all have any reason to believe
that uaps
and or what may be behind them may
intervene at some point to prevent
nuclear holocaust or some large iniquity
for example with russia
i personally don't have any evidence of
that we've uh we have a great deal of
evidence that they didn't
stop the testing of the first device the
use of it twice and the subsequent
testing by numerous nations on the earth
during that period of time so i don't
see why they would intervene otherwise i
don't have any evidence to point towards
uh any kind of motive
i can't even identify uh
who's behind the craft so getting to
their motives would be a very hard very
much longer stretch
yeah i'll go i'll go even even a little
more pointed than that um look they did
nothing they didn't interfere with
chernobyl they didn't interfere with
fukushima uh they didn't interfere with
the vaporization of 500 000 people uh
during world war ii uh hiroshima
nagasaki they didn't interfere during
the cuban missile crisis they didn't
appear
uh right now in the ukraine so
so the question is uh is there any
evidence to substantiate that they're
here to stop mankind from from uh
hurting ourselves well they haven't
stopped coveted they haven't stopped
climate change that they haven't stopped
world war ii korean war or anything else
and they haven't stopped world hunger so
um
you know i i it'd be nice if that was
the case but i haven't seen any evidence
to suggest that
um what i have seen is evidence to
suggest of some sort of isr intelligent
surveillance reconnaissance over nuclear
equities and technology that we have
seen we've been able to substantiate
that and the ability to interfere with
it but the question is are they
interfering it for good well um right
now there's no information to indicate
that at least not from my my perspective
do you have any idea what this cataclysm
is that people like ross coldheart refer
to
and if you dude has it been is it
impending has it been averted
i think i understand um
what ross is talking about i've spoken
to ross at length uh
privately
there's i know what ross is talking
about from the side of
the coin where i where i work and where
i'm interested in this subject i have no
connection to it whatsoever other than
as i often say the pop site geist
ufology now that's not to say that i
haven't studied some of the same things
that that ross has and other people like
grant cameron and others
that there is a cyclical nature to uh to
life on earth that there are changes
evident in the fossil record and in
sedimentary records
and things like that so
there may be a great deal of conflation
going on here between what we call the
entertainment aspect of ufology and the
need to
invigorate a subject and keep people
interested in it
vice the actual nuts and bolts again
and the reality of it um species have
gone extinct before there's no reason to
expect that we won't go extinct someday
so when people talk about cataclysms
i think it's important that we don't
conflate them
with um with popupology i'd like to
leave that to the geologists
and to the climatologists and the other
people who are who are making that their
specific focus
um i i you know i i
i'm not sure precisely what you're
referring to i mean cataclysms have
always been
been part of of of human evolution um
you know in fact one could argue we've
always been on the verge of a cataclysm
at any moment our species
there have been been historical
anecdotes whether it's nostradamus or
the mayan calendar or even the bible or
the bhagavad-gita or anything else um
you know
cataclysm armageddon whatever has always
been part of of of of
the human
storytelling
and for good reason because you do have
these these uh moments in time where
where things change so dramatically case
in point one could probably point to to
uh the last ice age where where when
when the earth was thawing out of the
ice age that was a major moment
and caused a lot of species you know to
to to disappear because because
environments change
the land bridge when that uh was no
longer crossable you isolated certain uh
genetic species from from intermingling
with each other um you know
it's it's always been part of of who we
are and always part of earth because
earth changes right look at the
dinosaurs right and and that was a hell
of a cataclysm right when you had uh
you had a meteor come down and white
about 90 of of animals on this planet um
that's just reality that's not you know
i'm not sure that's necessarily
something we all need to
to look at and say oh you know that's
coming we've we've always been
immersed in that again you can look
throughout history and see where mankind
in almost every religious text there is
some sort of reference to some sort of
cataclysmic event or that has had
occurred or will occur whether it's the
flooding stories of the earth uh and the
40 days of of of rain uh or other you
know
pick your pick your story right um that
we have always been telling ourselves
and the things continue to happen world
war iii just another example right
nuclear war
it's always it's always right around the
corner and for good reason because you
have
a lot of things operating in nature that
aren't necessarily in favor for a
species survival and so you have to
adapt if you want to survive whether
that's climate or or because of things
we do to each other
that's just the reality of life so i'm
not aware of any particular cataclysm
uh
story you're maybe referring to because
frankly
you know pick your story du jour there
bits
there's a lot of stories
let me be a bit more specific so ross
was referring to cataclysm as one of the
reasons for why the aliens i don't know
if they should be called aliens but
those from the future may come back into
the past
i i don't know i i really like ross i i
i think he is a deep thinker um
i really enjoy talking to him actually
even about these subjects and and
throwing conjecture against the wall
but i find myself um having a really
hard time saying what are we taught i
mean not to
not to play games but what are we
talking about here because if we're
talking about climatology or if we're
talking about
as we said sedimentary record and other
things like that of what has happened
before
we're throwing in aliens that we can't
prove we're throwing in a historical
record that's spotty
i agree that some of these things when
placed on the table together make a
certain amount of sense but i can't say
that the things we're placing on the
table make sense by themselves
and so there's a great deal of
conflation going on and i don't want to
say that anyone's using their
imagination too much but
i i think that it would just be my
opinion about
a lot of fiction and conjecture that
i've taken in over the years
which doesn't really apply
um in any way shape or form in the work
i'm doing right now so it's
it's imaginative and i think it's
interesting
but um again i can't i couldn't get
there as an investigator
um because i'm i'm making to an extent
making up one of the
um
one of the suspects
and i'm i'm assuming a story of one of
the complainants
to arrive to say that a crime has
occurred
it's the fruits of the poisonous tree so
it's it's
um if we had like a show about
conjecture and we wanted to really dig
into that you know we can get some
graham hancock or another expert maybe
from one of the ancient uh
ancient architect channels or something
like that i think we could have a really
interesting conversation but it just uh
it doesn't apply other than to my
opinion
sure i'll go also i'll add you know my
concern is right now let's just say
hypothetically we as a species right now
we have the ability to go back in time
my concern is the whole paradox issue
right you know there's a saying if i go
back and i kill my grandfather well then
i don't exist and so therefore i
couldn't go back in time to kill my
grandfather so
there's a paradox issue here and if
there's a species that that is for some
reason or us let's say coming back from
a future and i don't want to say the
future because we don't know if there is
you know the or perhaps a or multiple um
the bottom line is that if you if you
come back and interfere with the past
you may very well inadvertently affect
your ability to exist in the future and
change things irrevocably and in fact
you may change things for the worse not
the better so
you know i i think it's certainly
interesting to speculate but you know i
i think that's why
it's it's tough for us to to conceive
about going backwards in time i think we
can slow down through relativity time
can be slowed down
and it can be potentially even stopped
to some degree but
but to go backwards is a little bit
different you know you're asking the
river to run backwards and you can slow
it you can dam it up but to have a river
go backwards it's a little more more
tough than that
and so there lies the conundrum um you
know if if you go the mere fact that you
go back in time you know let's say
hypothetically to your time period which
is what would matter if you went back in
time you wouldn't want to go back to
some other
you know other parallel universe's time
because you're not going to affect your
your own
your own your own paradigm so you know
you have to take take it with a grain of
salt and i'm not sure
that um
i'm not sure we would want to do that
because of the risk you you would have
to to and then you have the question
about matter of the universe right so if
i take matter from the future and the
universe has only x amount of matter x
amount of energy and matter can and
energy can't be created destroyed now i
add more matter how how does that affect
the rest as it perturbs the existing
model of the universe by the mere factor
introducing more matter into a universe
that only has x matter you know and how
does that occur and now does that
initiate another potential big bang you
know these are the questions you have to
ask yourself it's seriously
whenever you you're you're you know
providing a theory about time travel um
again it's what like sean said it's fun
to speculate but
there's a lot more considerations that
one has to consider if if that was
really possible and would you really
want to do it
quick editor's quiddity here for those
interested in the details a positive
cosmological constant allows for the
creation of energy and energy seems to
only locally be conserved not globally i
think the uh we can all take the scene
from um
one of the avengers movies and goes end
game where they you know they ran
through all of the
all the different time travel movies
and they were trying to explain you know
they're all they're all wrong
you know they're getting it wrong
and they started talking about real
physics and the possibility of alternate
realities and alternate dimensions and
things like that but we have to ask
ourselves again if we don't have any
personal perception of that if we can't
detect it
um again assigning motive
is very um
very much just opinion
opinion weaving you know
i don't even know if i have a time
machine or if there's an alien what his
motive is what he wants
and agreed with lou again what are even
the mechanics of operating something
like i don't know you know it's it's far
beyond my ken
and just so you know lou you mentioned
at one point that the present is thick
for lack of a better word cigarette
burning as the analogy and for people
who are interested in a more
mathematical treatment of that i spoke
to someone named nicholas jason who gave
a formalism to indicate that the present
time is thick that you can't pick out a
particular point that as soon as you do
it's almost like honey so if you're
interested in that i'll put a link in
the description yeah no and we see that
very practically in in the world of of
of quantum physics and even the the the
expression or the description of an
electron you know again we
for for your audience who's probably my
age remembers in high school you learn
that
an electron orbits uh
the nucleus of an atom but in reality
that's not what's occurring we now
realize it's it's called an electron
cloud for a reason because of
predictability and the fact that the
electron can never be
isolated in a in a fixed position
um you can't do it and in fact is some
scientists now are speculating that that
is because the electron
uh is is is everywhere and nowhere at
the same time it is it is so small that
it may literally be zipping in and out
through the very fabric of space-time
uh and so it's nonsensical to to to try
to predict the position of an electron
because
there is no position it it's everywhere
and nowhere at the same time
around the nucleus of an atom and um you
know that's that's that's some of the
the observations we're beginning to see
now and let me add to that that the past
and the future are human semantic
constructs
it is always now
it always has been now from the
universe's perspective um the past is
not something that's sitting next door
to us
um it's
so
in another way people think of things
and we think when we say that the stars
are very far away the light took a very
long time to travel to us we're seeing
the past again that's a metaphor we're
not seeing the past we're seeing now and
now as those photons are here hitting
your eyes where at one point they were
not
and so these are arbitrary concepts a
lot of times so we've applied a linear
understanding to to something that
exists on a much deeper much deeper
spectrum
in a lot of ways
when we talk about going past going
future and i think a lot of what lew's
talking about is that reality is
anchored in now
and in the present and in the the
entropic state that we exist in at this
moment
and so there's so many variables to that
and we've jumped we're jumping to motive
you know
i i think that's that's something we
just have to keep in mind yeah i'll go
even a step further kurt too with uh
kind of piggybacking off of what what
sean said you know the whole notion of
here and now
is is almost nonsensical um
it's it's
let me give an example i ask you kurt
where are you where are you right now
let's do a little quick exercise uh for
you and your audience where are you
right now
[Music]
let's say toronto
canada okay where's toronto where is
toronto i don't know how to answer that
okay well where where's where's where's
canada
where's norway
right
right and where's where's our solar
system
where's our milky way
there is no here here okay we we we
invent here because we have to live in
an environment where
we are used to boundaries and borders in
order for us for things to make sense
but in reality the big scale of things
in the scale of the universe
the notion of here and now is really
nonsensical because depend depends on
where i am relative to everything else
here
go ahead sean sorry it's like trying to
pick out a specific electron from the
electron cloud
it's it's um
yeah it's it's
everything is moving
so dynamically
at all times that that a a location
is is not a concept it's only a location
it's only a location in a in a certain
regional area
and you have to have some kind of
substrate to measure that against
and we live in a universe that lacks a
substrate there's no snap to grid that
we can say we've you know we we're now
14 parsecs northeast to
you know
local global or cluster north what is
the what's that mean
you know how would you navigate to that
um
that's something that really that really
digs into my head how would we navigate
to a point in the past you have to
figure out its location in space time
[Music]
we haven't found space time yet to be a
thing to measure in that way
and in fact you know if you look at in
the the theory of of of
of
inflation of the universe during the big
bang early parts of the big bang and
even now as the expansion of the
universe continues to get bigger and
faster
you know scientists are now now stating
that space itself is space time itself
is is being created and that's how you
have this this expansion of the universe
occurring faster and faster and faster
uh and that's you know when you when you
when you look at that case in point let
me let me see if i can if i can bring
this to a little bit easier to
understand um the the universe has been
estimated to be almost not quite 14
billion years old right and yet when you
ask the scientists how big is our
visible universe from end to end they
say it's about
94 billion light years across well how
can that be because that means the
universe has to be expanding bit faster
than the speed of light well
not necessarily what's happening
in in theory is that actual space-time
itself is expanding as well
um think of
probably the best way to explain it
would be imagine um
water seeping up from the bottom of the
bathtub and filling up the bathtub
it's filling up from all sorts of little
pores water's coming out everywhere not
just out of the spigot but everywhere
it's starting to fill up the tub
if that is the case then
then
again the notion back to where we are in
the universe is always changing in fact
when when you say to yourself and it's a
little bit scary to do but you say i'll
be here tomorrow no you won't you will
never be here again and you you can't
it's impossible because
the the the entire universe isn't static
it's moving and the only way to know
where you are is only relative to other
people and where they are and by the way
are they just as lost as we are so and i
don't mean that just figuratively i mean
that physically you know we are all
kind of kind of scattered through the
winds together and the only way we can
kind of relate to each other oh you're
you're you're kind of close to me so i
guess relative you know you're you're
six foot and i'm five foot
you know nine and and and we gauge
things relative to each other but we
really have no idea
where we really are or even when we are
and that's
you know something to to ponder perhaps
we invented time so we know when to meet
for lunch tomorrow but in reality we
just observe entropy
it's it's there's a lot of stuff yeah
please that's okay i just like to bring
things down to a mathematical level for
some of the people who are more
interested so the relational view that
lou outlined you can read more about it
in a relational view of quantum
mechanics by carla rovelli and then this
arbitrariness of setting one's location
when lou was asking me where's toronto
and it's in canada and then where's
earth and so on that is called general
covariance and that's where the
principle of well that's where general
relativity comes out from so if you want
to learn more for those who are
interested in mathematical details
that's what you can look up
okay now i'm curious about the reason
for secrecy behind this whole uap
phenomenon and i'm curious do you
believe that it's profit driven
primarily or that it's so profit driven
by the private sector or profit driven
by the governmental sector or that it's
altruistically motivated like tom delong
may espouse or tom delong believes
are we talking what can we can you
identify what exactly are we asking
about what is the
there's much that is covered up about
the reason for secrecy you're asking
about what what is you're asking my
opinion on the on
it
it's my opinion just by looking at the
simple record that we that we can that
we can distill that that made front page
news that did get reported that wasn't
completely redacted
i think we see um a great a great deal
of shock and confusion and if we're to
assume
that some of what we all assume about
crashes and bodies and things like that
if that occurred
we're still debating what that would do
to our religions our society our culture
our stock market all of those things we
still debate that to today with the with
the pretty split
constituency of who believes that we're
ready and who believes that we're not
and i think we can see a natural
progression of not understanding
something wanting to understand it
before they
made it public
but then human nature probably i can
imagine took over
and so power mongering um
greed
uh idea mongering you know thought if
that makes sense um wanting to keep you
know important ideas to yourself i can
see that that would have happened
already but i still think that
the government that i the military that
i worked in and the government that i
operated in and around was made of just
regular folks like us
and
it this is an incredibly daunting
subject
and so i can see where
it would have continually been kicked
down the road now that's just my opinion
just from from looking at what's in the
public record
um
what do you mean by that it would have
been continually kicked down the road
no i've never met anyone who wants to
take responsibility for this
and it's one of the things that made lou
very interesting a few years ago when he
appeared was that he was he had the
courage to do it and he wasn't doing it
in the same way everybody else did it
and he wasn't asking for your money
and he you know he wasn't on the same
nonsensical you know the tv shows i
shouldn't say they're nonsensical
television shows but things that are
where you sandwich important information
in between fiction
um it always leaves a plausibility
deniability and and lou doesn't mess
with that stuff it's like look here's my
record and now we can see the people
that tried to try to silence him
and so it was very very different
um
where are all the other lose
we know they existed where are all the
other program managers we're the foreign
program managers
um they're not speaking up there's a lot
of
simple questions as to why whether
they've been threatened whether they're
under under nda
but i talk to a lot of people every day
who want to help in this subject very
high profile people
um
but but they don't want their names out
there yet attached to it they believe in
it they think it's real
but they're still waiting for that
tipping point to where we stop laughing
at it where it stops ruining careers and
ruining brands or we're changing
people's minds about you as an
individual
um that's primarily stigma that's
keeping them from speaking out
non-anonymous
i would say that that i would say that
primarily stigma and and um
and wanting to
let me try to make an analogy here that
if if i brought a um
if i came back to the
to the tribe around the campfire
and i brought a uh a power saw
what are we going to use it for
it has a purpose it's for cutting wood
but a lot of the folks in the tribe are
probably going to want to use it to go
take over the other tribe next door
because it's the most powerful weapon
they've ever seen
and right there we may just be talking
about human nature
but i think that there's so much of our
humanity wrapped up in the answers that
we all assume are part of this
that very few people have been willing
to take responsibility in any way shape
or form
lou
what do you believe to be the primary
reason
look kurt i'm um for lack of
transparency yeah i'm a little more more
practical and and probably a little bit
more um
less optimistic um
for our species on this particular
question
what if
there was
knowledge kurt
that
was
so volatile
so earth-shattering
that the mere knowledge of that getting
out could predicate
an action that could potentially
threaten the entire species
now what do i mean by that um
for just a moment
take off the scientific hat
take off your humanitarian hat take off
your
your philanthropic hat and put on a hat
of national security
um
you just we just talked about the fact
that there's no indication that these
things have been here to help us
okay um they're that so there's really
only three possibilities they're benign
uh or or if you will benevolent
or two uh they are malevolent they're
here to hurt us or three they're just
here to observe us and they're capable
of doing both good and bad like us well
if you were to put on your national
security hat for a second let's say
you're a general from the 1950s or 60s
and your job is to protect america and
all things good and great and uh the
height of the cold war and you've got
the you know the soviet bear across
there and
things are pretty tough right um and
nuclear proliferation is a real thing
now um
you have information that there is
something here that is can outperform
anything you have
and really um anything you have is is is
rather ineffective uh from a national
security perspective and there's a thing
out there um and it doesn't show that
it's being benevolent so it's only one
of two other options either malevolent
or it's like us
and we see this very careful
isr uh surveillance of our nuclear
equities it's interested in nuclear
equities well
some may look at that as what we call
preparation of the battlefield okay and
and let's just say hypothetically
there's a 10 percent chance u.s has a 10
chance that these things are bad or or
one day they're going to come here in
force and they're just they're they're
looking at us right remember you're
putting on your national security hat so
forget about everything else for a
moment your job is to be paranoid
and there's a small remote chance that
these things
are not good
um and maybe there is a plan for these
things at some point to come in force in
50 years from now
and if the mere fact you have this
conversation uh with the american people
what's going to happen well the american
people can start getting prepared
well you know i can tell you in real
life combat situations when we send in
long-range surveillance nurse teams you
know behind enemy lines the moment the
enemy finds out that we know um
that that that they know we're there
um the surprise element of surprise is
over and so ultimately hypothetically
imagine a scenario where maybe we had 50
years to prepare for something but now
that the cat's out of the bag
that existential action will happen
tomorrow and by the way we're not ready
for it we're not prepared for it we
don't have a counter measure we don't
have a capability to counter this and so
from a very real perspective a national
security perspective the mere fact that
you are acknowledging the existence of
something may predicate an action or an
act that you're not prepared to have
right now
um and so i i encourage you and your
listeners to just for a moment i'm not
asking you to be a national security
person but i'm asking you to suspend
your personal beliefs right now for just
a moment and put yourself in somebody
else's shoes who does feel that way
right now what do you do
if the mere fact of talking about this
could potentially cause a reaction that
you're not ready for as a country as a
civilization
right maybe that's the reason why you
decided to only brief certain presidents
who have a background in intelligence
maybe they were former directors of cia
but the other presidents who are career
politicians will be you know they're
here today gone in four years maybe you
can't even risk telling them
and so maybe the reason why this has
been kept secret so long is actually in
a weird sense some sort of sense of
patriotism by people
uh and and you know maybe maybe that's
how they justify it um
and i'll leave that at that as a you
know just a
as a counterpoint of forcing people to
think maybe a little bit
non-traditionally now do i think if that
happened to ever be the case that's
that's
that's that's a good explanation no
i still think that we have to be honest
with the american people you know it's
like going to i've said this before it's
like going to the doctor
just because i have cancer you know it's
bad news don't don't keep that from me i
want to know because maybe there's a
chance i can do something about it right
so but but do i understand that
mentality sure nobody wants to give
anybody bad news now am i saying that's
the case no i'm not it's just you ask me
one of the reasons why people want to
keep this secret well that's a really
damn good reason why people may want to
keep this secret because the mere fact
of not keeping it secret could cause a
reaction that you're not ready for yet
there's nothing you can do you don't
have a countermeasure so again from a
national security perspective you know
that that makes sense again i don't
agree with it but you know that
that's understandable what should i do
then as someone who
that's that that's the wrong question to
ask that's and sean sean can give you
advice on that [ __ ] i can't tell you
what to do
yeah that's that's my problem this is
see when we go down this rabbit hole
people want want to know what should
they do about it that's not for me to
answer that that's for you to answer
yourself i can't tell you what to do
about it i can't tell you what to i can
give you like look hey look you've been
diagnosed with cancer you should get
treatment but how you get that treatment
and who you get it from and how you
decide to do it that's on you brother
that's not me i can't and it would be
overstepping my balance to even begin
to this is where people go wrong in this
whole area of ufology and ufos because
they want well what do i do about it and
people are really quick to tell well
this is what you should do you should
subscribe and you should give me money
and i'll teach you how to do this that's
horse [ __ ] that's that's no
you figure that [ __ ] out that's you
don't ask me because i'm not smart
enough to tell you what's in your best
interest only you can make that decision
i can i'm smart to tell you what's in my
best interest but i can't tell you
what's in your best interest and i won't
and that's overstepping my bounds i
don't know if sean has a
i'm sure sean probably has his own
perspective but i'll i'll shake it now
i don't think lou is passionate enough
so sean if you could please
for me it comes down to the fact that um
you know while doing this the last
couple years i've been offered a lot of
opportunity opportunity that might have
been fun
but it would have tainted everything
that i thought was important about this
and it would have confused people and it
would have placed me into a bucket of
saying ah he's just trying to make money
he's just trying to do this that and the
other i've given a lot of thought to
that over the years man and what
motivates me and the reason that i'm
here and the reason that i'm not saying
what can i do who didn't come up to me
at at any point in the last four years
and go this is what i need you to do
sean that's that hasn't happened we've
become colleagues and we become equals
together working together but i had to
find my own road for this and for me i
had i had to really put a lot of thought
into that because at the time that i met
lou i was teaching meditation i was i
was trying to lead a very different life
and the con a lot of this the aspects
that bump into that kind of thing in uap
are still very important
however
that wasn't the most effective thing for
me the most effective thing for me was
taking my my career as a at arms and as
a chief in the navy and taking the story
of my involvement in the tic tac event
in 2004
and utilizing that moment in time that
we had with unidentified and with a few
other things
to reach out and have a conversation
with people who didn't have a chance to
see all that information who didn't
understand that this had occurred and
that it was real and then they began
socializing that at a higher and higher
level
until the people that can actually
affect actual change were reaching out
and they were interested in in
how we could do things and as we had
progressed along that line we created a
network of concerned individuals
and that's how i got here now a lot of
other people out there they have they
have very specific skill sets i get
contacted by lawyers i get contacted by
software developers and even even um
manufacturers diecast folks and you know
they're like how can we help and it's
like i don't need to cast anything
and i i can't afford a lawyer
and you know and it's like so it's like
i don't
you know when jfk said ask not what your
country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
what he was saying was stop
don't don't keep
asking for answers you have to find your
answers where do you become part of the
solution in here and i know that that
overwhelms a lot of people but it
doesn't have to be huge you know what i
mean not everybody's luke skywalker
some folks some folks are doing a great
deal of help
lifting lifting people up so they can
finally press a button or finally grab a
gold ring and if it's a team
none of that's ever i i'm kind of just
pontificating but none of that's not in
a vacuum man we have to find out what we
need what we need out of this it's not a
recruitable subject it's not like we get
enough buses full of people and we're
gonna drive to the thing and we're gonna
wave a sign and get what we need it's
not quite like that so kurt you want to
know what my number one advice is and
i'm going to let sean explain this
because
shawn does a better job than i do but
when people say they ask me what's the
first thing i should do
and this is going to sound a little
crazy but you know what i'm going to let
sean explain it because i think he
definitely gets it
my one word of advice is
turn to your children
turn to your loved ones
and love them
invest in your relationship with your
loved ones and your friends
start with that and people get mad it's
like well what the hell does that have
to do with with topic of uaps and
anything else this has everything to do
with it because if if if you don't stop
to do that
and realize what's really important in
life
then
everything else is is is
is irrelevant and i'm going to hit the
head real quick for a second because
i've been i've been drinking this and by
the way i haven't seen any you cats
drinking and you told me to drink beer
so
you took you told me i had to drink beer
so now i got to go to the bathroom a lot
so you can't blame me but i'm over to
sean because that's my one word of
advice
turn around
and and tell your loved ones that you
love them remind them that you love them
and that's that's where you start but
i'll let sean jump in on that because he
does a much better job explaining it
than i do
lou gave me that oh god
lou just a follow-up on this if you can
hold your bladder
yeah
okay well then think about this because
i'm curious
what is it that you tell your children
about the phenomenon you got it i'll
answer that after sean sean steps
when i first met lou this was too
daunting on the subject um it was too
big of a playing field there were too
many details and too much going on and
it was kind of freaking me out you know
because very early on a few years ago i
accepted that this was real all in a
rush and then started doing more
research in different areas
some of this can be pretty heavy
sometimes and
i turned to him and i i was i didn't
know what to do he said you need to
check your foundations
he's you know
basically what it came down to was
achieving world peace while coming from
a busted home where people are living in
fear or where there's no communication
and no love isn't worth what isn't
you're that's not
that's not the mission the mission here
is to i call it this kind of gets a
little woo but i call it my my
my creations and my covenants
that's that's what i'm beholden to and
those are my children and my wife
first of all and then that ex my circle
of family and my circle extends out
there to my friends and my family and
things and larger family and things like
that
but i am
i am truly beholden to those people in
my house to my wife and children
and i can't ignore them and that means
that i have to choose to be the right
person in that house and that means that
i have to choose to look for my faults
and to be self-aware and to try to be
the best person that i can in that
environment because it is truly where
everything else stems from
if you're not
doing the right thing with the people
that you love the most that are closest
to you
why do you feel the need to to mount a
horse and ride off after off on this
crusade to change the world truly start
changing the world where you are and
where you begin and then turn towards
slaying the dragon and it makes slaying
the dragon a much more logical much more
easy process because your heart's in a
state where it knows right from wrong
and it knows where to go next it's not
bogged down by by the worry that frankly
that we all take to work with us every
day you know what i mean we all get up
in the morning wondering about the go to
bed angry wondering about the argument
of the kids grades like this
how is how is this relationship panning
out are we gonna separate
we've all got these things going on but
if we all decided to take the kind of
effort that we wanted to apply to
ufology turned around in the short term
even and applied it in our own lives in
our homes
suddenly these larger battles become
much easier
thank you sean
now lou
do you have an answer to that question
which is
what is it that you tell your family
slash children about the phenomenon
if i need to find their own answers
we're all trying to figure this out
together
and it's okay
to to be excited it's okay to be scared
it's okay to be
whatever human emotion you you need to
ascribe to it um you know it's it's okay
there's
i i think
i think honesty and truth is
is the best remedy always um that will
get us through pretty much anything um
even even when things are even when the
news is bad even when the news is good
right um
and
i i try not to think for anybody don't
try to think for my kids or my spouse or
my friends or you know the only person i
can think for is me
and
you know i tell my kids you know just
be kind to one another be kind to the
world as much as you can you know try to
give back more than you take
um
you know because i think whether you're
talking about ufos or anything else
that's sound advice if you want to if
you want to
if you want to think about ufos well you
know it depends on on how you lead your
life as a human being
which is going to take you down the road
look there's there's
there's a lot of people out there um
that want to hijack the narrative
but it's not just because it's a ufo
thing it's because that's the kind of
people they are they will do that with
anything and any opportunity that
they're given ufos is just
one of them but there are people out
there that will try to do that and
hijack that and um
it's uh it's a shame but you know i
i can't change those people i'm not
going to i'm not going to waste my time
changing those people you know they have
to deal they have to deal with that on
their own terms
and that's on them look there's bad
people i face them in washington i face
them on the battlefield you know i face
them in
every day you know when you when you
when someone is trying to to to mug you
or carjack you or something like that
there's just bad people out there
um
you know
so anyways that's that's my
that's my two cents maybe three cents
okay i'm going to get to some audience
questions and just so you know the set
of audience questions this time is
of extreme high quality
and that's saying plenty given some of
the quality that's been on this channel
and much of that's due to
the culling of the questions and the
ordering of the questions from that ufo
podcast which is to be specific andy and
dan and they graciously helped me out
with these questions so if you like the
theories of everything podcast and i'm
someone who's asinine and sophomoric
when it comes to this topic then you'll
gain a great deal from watching that ufo
podcast and the link is in the
description to subscribe to them so this
question comes from matriac directed to
both of you if you could start over and
pursue a different educational path with
the hopes of understanding uaps more
fully what degree would you choose
sean you want to tackle that one
yeah
um
i don't know if the curriculum exists uh
it's a tough question there's not one
for me that fits it
i'm a generalist um
i'm i'm a student of the human condition
sorry it's an interruption i'll give you
an example earlier
about a few months ago when i was
speaking with you lou and you gave me
the question kurt what if you wanted
some
thing to survive generations and
generations and millions of years and i
said well perhaps
nanotechnology or meta materials and
launch it into space so that's materials
engineering and you said well perhaps
you should think about dna okay so
that's biology so those would be two
different fields to go in if one was
thinking about the preservation of some
objects for some length of time
can i jump in on that
please
i would uh
i would probably start with philosophy
and why is that
because philosophy is one of the few
areas that teaches you how to think and
not what to think right
it's in the topic of uaps it's not a
matter of what it's how
you know how do we process a data
how
how
how does this apply to our species where
we're going where we're from et cetera
um there's very few academic pursuits
that teach somebody how to think most
people and i can tell you this from
personal experience with my children
most schools teach kids what to think
and that's a problem because we've
forgotten what what what real teaching
is about you know i can instruct
somebody on how to do something
but real teaching real teaching is is
something different
um
you know a lot of the the the
eastern philosophies understood that you
know it's it's it's not teaching
somebody
the the specifics it's teaching somebody
how to
how to find the data themselves um and i
think i would probably
start with that maybe do some reading um
on people who who
who look at things maybe a little bit
differently right and aren't prescribing
you what to think but more importantly
again how to think
i was going to joke philosopher ninja
because because frankly i completely
agree with lou i don't wanna
i don't wanna hit a
buzzword by saying consciousness because
a lot of people that's another conflated
term
um
but philosophy with an eye towards
protecting the human race i think is
something that that i that's what i
would want i would want someone who's
looking out for all of the people
who can think deeply and who can who can
arrive at different solutions because we
have this is a different paradigm this
is not in the rule books this is if
anything has been other in our
experience it's uap
and so we our ability to understand that
is going to
absolutely begin in our ability to
understand ourselves first
so that when we encounter this thing
that is so strange that it that it's
it's so beyond our understanding
that we have the the
we have the self-awareness to survive
that
you know the the old the old
story do you do you give a man a fish or
do you teach a man how to fish right
feed him for a day or
or feed him for life
and i think that's what is important
here you know people should should not
ask for for a fish piece of fish
you know learn learn how to fish and and
ask the questions yourself and and find
the answers yourself so you're not
relying on other people to give those
answers for you
is there another field so let's imagine
that philosophy was underway you're
allowed a double major
um
i would say probably
is there a course on on comic relief
um look you gotta you gotta keep your
sanity in this you can't lose yourself
uh i'll be the first one
to to admit that you know there's times
i'll call sean or others that i trust
you know in the middle of the night just
to vent something you know can you
believe
that you know you do all this and and
people are out there just making a
[ __ ] about you
um and you got it you got to take it
with a grain of salt um and it's hard it
really is especially when you're trying
to do something really to the benefit of
everybody and and people ascribe all to
your motives and they're out there you
know
i mean it's i'm not going to go into
detail but it's it's it's it's bad and
and
you got to be you got to be willing to
um take take that kind of heat for me
you know i i spend a lot of my time
cutting my teeth in in various bad
places around the world and you know
i'll tell you in combat i never
you know when someone's shooting at you
or rocketing you or murdering you i
never took it personally i didn't like
it right
but i never took it personally because
that's warfare
but this is different when your own
fellow citizens are are doing things
that they do sometimes because of
personal bias or whatever you know
selfish motivations in some cases
that hurts because these are your fellow
citizens right this is the reason why
you went to war in the first place and
now these people are
are
doing and saying terrible things
um you've got to learn how to take that
with a grain of salt and not take it
personally and it's tough it really is
curb you know
it is
you know we're all human beings we all
have emotions we're all emotional
creatures
and i think it's it's my advice would be
look you know
go see a comedy you know learn learn
learn a course in in uh in uh
you know comic relief because you gotta
you gotta keep yourself seen otherwise
you will
you will you will you will burn out um
far far too early
sean
um
part of me wants to say game theory
honestly you know i want to take your
questions seriously i think philosophy
game theory um an understanding of the
martial sciences
and an ability to think
with self-awareness to be a self-aware
human being to be a fully realized human
being who has done their shadow work for
lack of a better word you know in a
jungian sense
who's who's climbed through their hero's
journey uh who knows what those things
mean because they are learned enough
to to try to understand what this life
is and to try to find out what the uh
the archetypal similarities between
humans are that we can use to find
commonality and validity
and someone that seeks to truly
understand what this is because it's
this is very multi-layered it's not as
simple as just a volkswagen in a field
with a dead body
if it was i think we'd already be there
okay this next question comes from jesse
mitchell of american alchemy and the
link to his youtube channel is in the
description and it's directed toward you
lou how is your background in paris
psychology dovetail with the phenomenon
wow so um great question uh from jesse
i uh
my
my background
uh in formal education was microbiology
immunology and parasitology not
parapsychology but as a lot of people
know i did
i did spend some time in my career
working alongside people like hal put
off and whatnot and kick green and folks
that have been
uh exposed to that side of the us
government regarding um
[Music]
paranormal i guess we can call it
let me let me state this first and
foremost um
let's not forget everything in science
is paranormal until it becomes normal
okay this this very phone here 100 years
ago certainly paranormal
um if i say the word parachute
people think of a life-saving device
that deploys and helps you hit the
ground more with a whomp instead of a
thump uh if i say the word paramedic you
think of a first responder someone there
who's giving you an iv and maybe saving
your life right
um
they're all based in the latin word para
you know beside or above and then
whatever the word is well you say
paranormal just means beyond normal
but the associated stigma with the word
paranormal
really really paralyzes any further
conversation because people all of a
sudden will kind of look they'll [ __ ]
their head maybe they'll smile at you a
little bit and tell like what do you
mean paranormal well
i just mean something that hasn't been
normalized yet
everything in science
by definition again is paranormal until
it becomes normal let's not forget that
every law and principle we have in
science now started off as someone's
wacky zany idea
but look at galileo right he almost they
almost almost killed him for the fact
that he proposed that the earth was not
the center of the solar system based
upon
copernicus and and yet there were people
that even refused to look through his
telescope
because it was an insult it was an
affront to their preconceived notions
right it was paranormal
and you know here we are now
looking at it quite normally and so
um
i think i think we have i think we
forget that mother nature has a vote
that mother nature is wondrous and
mother nature always defies
labels she defies definition most of the
time every time we try to describe what
life is and put in a nice neat little
box
she proves us wrong
she proves that she is paranormal let me
give an example kurt when i was a kid i
learned that all life was basically um
it was it was based upon upon
photosynthesis right
uh all life
and it turns out that's not the case
there's there's animals in the deep
parts of the ocean that survive off of
chemosynthesis uh near black smokers
then you learn that all life uh depends
on
has to have dna well
now along come things like viruses where
we realize well it has rna it doesn't
have dna and yet it still replicates and
does a lot of things that living things
do so is that life
then you have extremophiles that live
the you know deepest parts of of high
pressure antarctic uh
uh very cold very high pressure ice
miles beneath the antarctic ice miles
beneath the the surface of the of the
earth itself in fact
even uh in the tallest mountains in fact
we find microbial life hitching rides on
our rockets into space and frankly doing
quite well
um
so what does that mean what does that
mean well it means that maybe maybe most
of the universe is paranormal
uh it is just beyond our reach and and
you know our quest is to make the
paranormal normal
um how does it prepare you for
for this topic
i think it keeps you humble
um to some degree
i think it's amazing i'm not scared of
it i think it's wondrous i think the
human being is is the most profound
complex piece of machinery and i think
there's other aspects to the human being
that we're we were just now beginning to
explore i think life itself
you know let me ask you this per you you
have quite a big background in physics
so um
i'm not nearly as smart or well versed
as you in this field but let me ask you
a question
what is um
what is energy what is it
can you define it for me
how about let's do an easier one how
about matter what's what's
what's matter what what is matter
technically matter is what is a part of
a matter field and there's a technical
definition for matter that's based on
observations
this question of what is then you can
ask well what is the number five and
then what is anything
anytime one gives an answer then it's
like a child asking why behind that
question and that's valid correct
well my point being is that that that we
have these principles in science such as
gravity such as matter such as energy
we've described we even have mathematics
to describe how they behave and yet we
still don't know what it actually is
what what is it what what is it
yeah here's a question for you lou about
that it's something i've been thinking
about what answer could someone give
that would be satisfactory like what
could an answer be
that would make someone say okay now i
understand what it is
well we may be asking the wrong question
we may what it is may be nonsensical
because maybe maybe the question is why
is it they may not be a what it might be
a why it might be aware it might be a
when believe it or not it may not be a
what let me throw in that
folks should should be sorry this is
going to make me sound really old folks
should use their dictionary more
because we have so many words in this
field specifically that have assumed
meanings
due to the way they've been used in the
past and associated that color people's
judgment on things for example if i said
to you uh the occult
that paints something in all of our
heads but at the moment
my right hand is a cult
now if you don't understand what that
word means
you're painting you're painting your
ignorance with your perception
you're telling me that that
we waste so much time with people who go
down these assumptive rabbit holes based
on what they think words mean and the
way that people use them and they assign
they just keep running with it and i
want us to back off on that in the
community in general and start using
better words like we have to explain the
word paranormal paranormal doesn't mean
ghostbusters it means the edges of
perception
it that's it's it's that simple now some
people want to say it means ghosts and
goblins and werewolves
and boogams and all this other stuff
and well maybe that's what we want to
investigate
but that's not the
we can't jump to these continual
conclusions
so
i'm just so evidence-based when it comes
to this i love to talk the philosophy
but we do mix the philosophy with the
nuts and bolts a lot of times and they
can makes make far too far too great of
a leap i think
okay this next question comes from bill
yates it's a live question and says i
have fantasia so it means that one lacks
a mind's eye lacks inner sound feeling
and even hearing how does lou and you
sean as well think the phenomenon would
interact with someone such as himself
such as billiat
i would say perhaps even more intimately
we don't know because
people who suffer from that also
sometimes have other abilities that we
don't really have because they have a
heightened sense in other areas
um we know that there are people for
example who are blind and they can
echolocate they can actually use sound
to to have in their minds eye and
understanding of the environment around
them now that seems kind of crazy for us
and yet we see it in nature all the time
whether it's dolphins or bats or
anything else
um
you know there are people who who are
certainly
suffer from for example um
autism extreme for some forms of maltism
and yet
they have photographic memory they can
do incredible extreme mathematical
computations in their head they can
their their their piano uh virtuosos
right and have never never had any
formal training in it how is that
possible well it's possible because the
human brain uh is first of all it's
wonderfully equipped and it's an
incredible organ
but it's it's it's it's still very
little understood about the human brain
and
um
you know some sometimes there's an old
i'll answer your question but maybe a
little bit more succinctly um
there was a a young student uh who was
trying to learn from the master and the
master says do you do you now see and
young student says no master i've been
looking for months and months and months
uh at the sunset you've been telling me
to look at uh near the mount over the
mountain and and i and i i still don't
see and the master says to the student
in order to see sometimes you have to
close your eyes
and uh
you know there you go right sometimes
sometimes you can actually see more
clearly by closing your eyes and you can
see with your eyes open in other words
we have preconceptions that could be
removed and then that would give us a
greater understanding or insight
yeah i mean sometimes our you know
sometimes our sense is foolish look at
an optical illusion right an optical
illusion is just that where our eyes are
telling us one thing but reality is
something different right and in this
case our senses are failing us
not all senses are necessarily
beneficial and they can be fooled they
can be spoofed right
human vision is just another sensor
collection system like hearing and
touching and tasting and whatnot um and
and we know they can be spoofed our
feelings can be spoofed right you can
betrayed by by someone our site can be
spooked you have optical illusions our
hearing can be spoofed uh you know we're
not perfect systems we we we they can be
flawed and sometimes
filtering out certain inputs certain
data can actually be beneficial perhaps
sorry john i kept interrupting you
oh no man that's okay um interestingly
enough without an official diagnosis i
believe i suffer from a fantasia as well
um i don't possess a very
vibrant inner mind's eye
except upon waking from dreams or
frankly very vivid trance states
where i've taken myself down through
meditation to a
a different place
for me that was
finding out that the word fantasia
existed to me was very important to
understanding myself and my mind's eye
and what my personal
inter inner experience is
that led to researching things like
interoception
understanding the inner workings of the
body and the perception of the inner
workings of your body
something you can do through meditation
is to actually start to pinpoint certain
places of the body and then start to
understand their processes
but beyond that i put
because of
things i've witnessed and experienced
and
i'm very lucky to have witnessed and
experienced some things in the company
of others
um especially some of the
the harder to accept things that maybe
some people would
consider excuse me consider like
poltergeist activity or things like that
i've been lucky enough to have other
witnesses with me to at least
say that we saw that thing we may not
know why or what but that led me to
research periphrenia
and peripherania is like having
schizophrenia without the bad parts
and i did a i did a great deal of
searching you know down the co-morbidity
of those things and
i find it very interesting that the
phenomenon interacts with human
consciousness in a way that can mirror
mental illness
it can and it seems that some of some
if
one perseverates on these ideas without
finding validity or answers
that it may be one of those triggers for
mental illness
now whether those are parts of our
fundamental archetype of our
consciousness or not or whether that's
directly due to the phenomenon or not i
can't say
i think all of us has to take the time
to go
what's up with me what's my list of
things going on with me what can i
change what can i understand
and
and how can i be the most
effective human being while observing my
own life
um i don't know if that makes sense i
don't know a lot of people that are
interested in living their life in real
time
if that makes sense
a lot of folks are looking to jump from
one dopamine fix to another
fear avoidance risk avoidance and
pleasure seeking and a lot of people
would say that that in itself is the
human condition and i don't want to say
that i'm holier than now or better than
anybody just because i want to check out
of the societal aspect of a lot of
things
and delve deeper into what a lot of us
call the matrix
you know casually um
but i think that that's where many of
the answers to this are going to are
going to lie for a lot of people
we were talking off air lou and sean
and myself about how
how uncomfortable it is at least for
myself and many others judging by the
comments it can be to study this
phenomenon and just consciousness in
general and how that's something that
almost no one talks about i have an
episode with carl firsten who is a
neuroscientist one of the if not the
most cited neuroscientist just on this
on how destabilizing and debilitating
can be i'm still recovering from
well i
you if you want you can watch that
episode people who are interested by the
way i consider it to be the most
important episode of all the theories of
everything podcasts because it sets the
stage and talks about something that you
may feel extremely uncomfortable with
and think that you're alone but you're
not and you may think that is hopeless
but it's not
jacob lizzo from signals the youtube
channel the link to that will be in the
description asks to both of you let's
pretend tomorrow an unidentified craft
crashes out in the nevada desert and you
are both tasked with recovering the
craft considering your experience and
your knowledge what sort of precautions
would you take what sorts of technology
and human resources would you bring with
you to aid your investigation
my experience and knowledge in that
would come from aircraft investigation
and aircraft recovery
so i first set up a uh
a curriculum so to speak with my team
that
that spoke about you know what i learned
about
first of all you have to when you arrive
on the scene of some of the especially
of a catastrophic failure of any kind of
vehicle
you have to understand that as soon as
you get there you you're going to have
exposure of chemicals
um fuel
depending upon you know what kind of
craft it might be it could be radiative
you know we we had portions of our of
our training that really you know what
if a satellite came down or something
like that
in the wrong place and this was just
from this was from my law enforcement
training because i had traffic accident
aircraft accident investigator training
as well um
i would start there then i would delve
into the the the
established program
uh programs of record that what they
studied well they studied
radiation radiative effects of something
that appeared to be emitting
high energy for lack of a better word
um
i i would get down to first the first
the most important thing to me would be
making sure that my team got in and got
out with everything they came in and got
out with that they were safe safety is
the number one priority and and
after that it would be
really just dealing with the
environmental factors um the people that
i would send to do something like that
frankly i would not send scientists um i
would send people that were i would send
people that were able to
immediately respond to environment
coordinate off and then i would call in
the scientists so
i'm kind of doing that in real time i've
never been involved with anything like
that involved you know involving uap but
i can take what we did with aircraft and
maintaining public safety personal
safety of the teams and i could extend i
can i can extrapolate that out to even
more stringent safety measures and an
even more cautious
approach
you know because in the end i would
treat it as a crime scene we treat in as
a first responder we treat everything
like a crime scene because it maintains
the evidentiary value of everything you
can't just go stomping through something
unless
you're unless it's to save life or live
if that makes sense so we wouldn't trump
a crime scene unless it was to save
somebody else so i would look out for
personal safety i would look out for uh
for
um
you know ensuring evidentiary value was
maintained uh that forensic evidence was
was maintained under the proper
conditions the chain of custody was
maintained under the proper conditions
and that frankly the right people were
the ones giving reports the initial team
should be giving data driven reports
um
and
conclusions and and investigating great
in-depth for forensic investigations
would come later
i would um i would do pretty much the
same thing um you know in essence and
that's probably because shawn and i come
from similar backgrounds
but first of all i'd set up a perimeter
to secure it
then you have to come up with ways to
transport it safeguard it study it
analyze it ultimately exploit it
and of course you're taking precautions
so like for example hazmat how do you
transport hazardous material right how
do you protect your people
from being contaminated chemically or
radiologically right and then of course
you want to handle it very much like you
would perhaps a tsa investigation of an
airplane crash right you don't know what
you're coming up to so you've got to
you've got to approach it as everything
is potential evidence
and so i think
uh you know you don't know what you
don't know there's the big challenge
right if there's some sort of of danger
that you're unaware of well then you're
unaware of it there's not a whole lot
you can do to prepare for something that
you don't know exists
uh so what you do is you you approach it
you know in the way that you do know how
to approach things that that are perhaps
similar again like an airplane crash and
that's that's how how i would approach
it
oh i'll take i'll get right into that
man
the first guy that walks into the the
settlement that only has in that battle
carrying a sword
every person carrying an atlatl in that
place wants to exploit that sword
they want to exploit the knowledge of
the person holding the sword what is
that material how did you get it so
sharp how is it so strong where did it
come from how do i get one and that's
the job frankly of the united states
government and the military and other
apparatuses that's part of what they do
as part of our national defense if a mig
crashed into alaska which or any other
place and you know the during the high
the height of the coal
cold war
the exact same team that we're
describing would have come in and done
the same thing they would have they
would have gotten that evidence gotten
into a place said how the hell does this
mig work what frequencies are they
transmitting on how fast does the engine
go what's the
load rate bearing rate of the wings and
the weapons pylons
that's what exploitation means it's and
that's why i say semantically in a
military retrieval sense it means go get
the thing and figure out how it works
and figure out how we can make it work
to keep our people safe
and that's what it means it doesn't mean
exploit in the negative sense that we
often use
with with other conversations you know
what i mean an exploited individual or
something like that where someone is
using them because in this sense we're
talking about material
okay material can be used
people should not be used
so material theories things like that
that's what the exploitation is it's an
unpacking and understanding
yeah kurt there was actually just last
week there was a headline in major news
outlets about a crashed f-35 that fell
off the deck of a carrier doing landing
and
the chinese and the us were in a race to
recover it now why do you think the
chinese were in a race to recover a
crashed fus f-35 aircraft
well because they wanted to exploit it
so
you know that's that's
that's not uh unusual
you know countries do this all the time
i see i see okay euphoric gur asks to
both of you are you aware of encounters
hostile or otherwise where different
types of uaps have been observed
interacting with each other
i'll uh i'll jump in first
i've said this before and let me let me
emphasize this again
there is a difference between
potential threat and hostile intent
okay um
you know if
there is lots of technology out there
that if i misuse it will hurt me now is
it the intent of that technology to hurt
me no it's just a product of me not
understanding the technology
um
the fact that we looked at potential
biological effects or consequences
in a tip and are continuing now in this
new effort uh in the law
shouldn't be a surprise to anybody
should not be confused as hustle intent
people say oh you're fear-mongering no
it's not fear mongering you know if i
put my hand in a car door and i slam the
car door my hand's gonna hurt okay
there's a threat i'm gonna break some
bones in my hands and and do damage is
it the intent of the car to hurt me no i
just it's it's my own fault i didn't
understand how the technology worked and
i got hurt by it right um and so
you know there is there is information
to suggest that
people have been injured by by uap
technology was it necessarily on purpose
we don't have any information to suggest
that necessarily but then if you talk to
people
who claim to have personal experiences
in this you know a lot of them claim to
be taken against their own will well
that's in my from my perspective that's
crime that's called kidnapping and then
some people claim that they've been been
been touched well that's assault right
potentially battery
um you see where i'm going with this
right so so
you know it's um
it's it's it's a it's a hard question to
answer because you can ask anybody out
there and somebody will probably give
you a a different answer
i believe this person was referring to
the uaps interacting with other uaps
rather than people
oh i i you know i don't know like like
fighting each other is that is that yes
yes have you are you aware of that like
different types of them is that what
you're saying yeah i'll reread the
question are either of you aware of
encounters hostile or otherwise where
different types of uaps have been
observed interacting with each other
so there is there is you know obviously
if you look at some of the the old text
and there's something called the
nuremberg incident in europe
where there was reports of what seemed
to be some sort of dog fight back in the
1600s apparently um and it was recorded
in something called the it was in
nuremberg germany right and they had
paintings of this of different rod
shapes and disc shapes and
and what cigar-shaped vehicles
apparently fighting each other like in
what seems to be some sort of dogfight
over time
um
you know i i i can't say that was the
case in atip um but there is some
historical information of course i
wasn't there so i can't i can't tell you
all i can tell you is that allegedly
those type of things may have occurred
in the past but we didn't see any of
that in in a tip
i was going to say the nuremberg wood
cutting as well
and and other than that i don't have a
really good example you know and i'm
willing i'm willing to give that one
credence it's an excellent it reads
really well and when you look at the
wood cutting
the
it's very easy to complete it with
modern reports it's a very interesting
story i'd love to know what really
happened i don't know
but um
in general i've never i've never
encountered that in my own work
i mean there's historical even in
religious texts right where where you
talk about uh the the vamana uh in in
hindu text that would fight each other
um and even some mayan texts as well of
of
different crafts engaging each other um
there was a very interesting stone that
i had the privilege i have some pictures
actually very interesting pictures
um that i took in peru in front of the
the air force intelligence office in in
lima peru
they actually have a formal ufo program
um that is run by the government and
they do very well with it actually it's
a formal investigation that they do of
any reported ufo incidents
and there in front of the
in front of the air force intelligence
building are several
stones
uh inca stones
and these are real legitimate inka
stones well i gotta tell you you gotta
you should look at some of these stones
because
it's pretty incredible um some of the
things what the what these stones are
depicting
uh you know really gotta get you
scratching your head like like people
using telescopes which by the way didn't
exist back then
and flying vehicles that have fire
beneath them and what appears to be a
tail gunner and the stars and the moon
and
i mean someone obviously had a pretty
good understanding of uh of of you know
the earth being around his celestial
bodies
um
a long time ago to make these stones and
it's it's very interesting now is that
that proof positive or evidence of
anything no you know could just be
someone's wild imagination
you know there's there's lots of that
out there but you know could be
something else too
so
okay this question comes from miles
coloradan if i mispronouncing that i
apologize it's directed to both of you
are you aware of attempts to make
contact with uaps and if so what were
the results are they still taking place
i'm not aware of it i'm not aware of any
official um
programs like that or efforts like that
i have spent a great deal of time
studying all of the different um
contact groups around the world
to include
various mediums um
and and so-called channelers
that claim to be in contact
with various
and sundry
alien civilizations that they have
all of this deep
knowledge about that i can't verify any
of it
um and when i take the each of these
little slots and and ideologies that
form around these folks and start
comparing what one has to say against
the other it's very rare that i can find
much in common
and so
i'm not i don't know where to go with a
lot of that information
um it's hard for me to collate it's hard
for me to understand
i would ask you define contact
what does that mean contact does it mean
sitting down having a beer does it mean
uh making yourself known does it mean
conversation what what what does contact
mean um
you know i've people are aware that
there were efforts
by the u.s government to to collect
information more information on these
things
um
but what do you mean by kant do you mean
like a close encounters where we sit
down and we have coffee together we you
know we
we talk about things or are we talking
about contact being just the providing
of evidence proof that that they're real
and that we want more to collect more
information you know
yes there were efforts to try to
try to collect additional information
maybe create a scenario or the
environment where
perhaps these things would show up
and in so doing we could collect
information now is that contact well
some could argue yeah that's a form of
contact you know it's like like like
when people said we communicated well
that depends what's your definition of
communication when
when i'm when i'm waving to you from
across the room i'm communicating i mean
i'll be communicating too verbally but
i'm communicating to you when we
scramble on f22 to go intercept the
russian bear off the coast of alaska
we're not talking to him but we're
communicating make no mistake we're
communicating an intent
so again when you say contact um
that's a bit broad i i need that more
narrowly defined in order to answer that
question probably properly sure i'm sure
you've heard of a disc that's been sent
off into space and it has two people i
don't recall the name of it so something
it's on the board it's on uh the voyager
pioneer probes
right okay so that was earth's attempt
at trying to communicate with whoever is
a civilization that may not share our
language has something similar occurred
between
the us government or between
humans as
doesn't have to be relegated to the us
government and the uaps
something that says look i'm trying to
show you the connection between this
symbol and some intent a symbol how
about that communicating with symbols
let me ask you a question kurt why do we
make the assumption that an exterior
force is going to make communication
with a governmental agency or entity
why not you know and and again why not
in a fash why not communicate in a
fashion
that was
hard to ignore
you know what i mean but instead these
seem to be part of me for using the word
the clandestine and piecemeal
when it comes to interaction with the
public
and if what lou is saying is that it's
possible that we may have
created an environment that was
conducive to them wanting to appear for
lack of a better word
um
again it still speaks of of a a missing
piece here you know um and it is that
let me see let me say this and i'm not
i'm not indicating that i want to use
deadly force okay but in my training
when we learned about deadly force we
learned about the deadly force triangle
years ago and that included opportunity
intent and capability
now we know that these these craft have
a great deal of capability
and their capability seems to open up a
great deal of opportunity for them
but the question is still the intent
and communication as we said i
communicate with my dog every day i
think she and i have very different
ideas of what we're communicating to
each other and what it means
and so communication is a very broad
word waving at an at a cow is
communicating for me
but the cow may not perceive it that way
i may not even know that it was
communicated with
so
seriously finding a common language
finding a baseline for this
is is we have a lot and i'm not downing
your questions they're the same
questions i haven't you know and i ask
them and me and my friends talk about
the same stuff around the fire and i'm
just being cagey because i'm on a
podcast
but
the fact is is we just don't know a lot
of this stuff
you know so
i i do really try to be careful with
with stating my opinion on some of this
stuff because my opinion has changed a
lot over the years based on the data
based on my own personal experience and
growth
and and so it's a
i don't know i just i try to be careful
i'm willing to be courageous but i try
to be careful
are you aware of psychedelics being used
as a channel of communication
i'll tell you that i know that there's a
lot of people out there trying to
utilize that right now and they have
their own beliefs
and they have some certain commonality
of experience when we're talking about
those that are
approaching it from a scientific fashion
those that are
um connected with
um pardon me for not remembering his
name the terence mckenna's brother
um is doing a great deal yeah dennis is
doing a lot of great work down south i
believe in central america and setting
up an institute and a college
to study these things their effects in a
pragmatic scientific and in fashion
utilizing control groups and
modern therapy i think that's very
important because it is the the
undiscovered country of human
consciousness is to go down the rabbit
rabbit hole of
of uh loss of self frankly
um
now does that tie directly into what we
see in the skies and what we purport to
and what we hoped might be have crashed
pardon me for hoping a crash on anyone
but hoping that there might be evidence
right now we all hope that there's that
eventually some day we might find that
that smoking gun we all talk about that
gives us clarity
but
i still don't know if the spectrum we're
looking at i feel like our needle goes
all over the place all the time because
we're using a word like phenomenon and i
think that's important i think i think
the the facile idea that we have taken
the word ufo and replaced it with some
new no we used a better word
because most of stuff that i am
encountering regardless of whether it's
unidentified or an object it's certainly
not exhibiting flight characteristics
and that just gets under my skin
that we're constantly saying flight
flying flying listen that's a that's a
kindergarten attitude to think it's in
the sky it's flying
it's i'm sorry to say it like that it's
that's not that we need folks
to
get out of that muck get get get up get
up a level
on some of this stuff it really opens up
new doors of thought it opens up new
possibilities as to what we're working
with when you start looking at it
differently and not in the science
fiction and as you've been told aspect
i agree we need to be more accurate with
our terminology right this goes back to
what sean was saying in the beginning
as far as our lexicon you know
please do you know be accurate when you
when you speak
because it you know what words have
meaning and a lot of people just kind of
throw words around and you know they're
not really doing their due diligence
understanding and it confuses things and
you know we have to be accurate that's
why science is is
to where it is today because it involves
accuracy
math right um
you want to be accurate when you're when
you're describing things like this
especially something that we don't know
be accurate in the unknowns um and i
think that's you know sean said it
perfectly you know you have
flight is a fundamental you have four
fundamental forces you have thrust lift
drag and wait
and when you understand those you have
flight you have control surfaces you
have wings and and rudders and ailerons
and elevators
but we're not seeing any of those
associated technologies and people say
well it's a semantics no it's it it is
but it's important it's important
semantics
right otherwise just call every animal
an animal right forget if it's a blue
whale or a human being or an elephant
it's just an animal well no
there's differences key differences and
we have to be we have to be mindful of
that
yeah i like to say on this podcast
there's this word that people say with
denigration it's liquidity now quiddity
means it's a hair splitting distinction
but it also means a peculiar essence an
odd feature in eccentricity
something that sets it apart and so i'm
a fan of delineation of taking what it
is
yeah yes so beautiful
this man some of these questions are so
great this one comes from chris pass
in the prior toe interview lou asked
kurt about making something that would
last a million years and kurt said many
materials harder than diamond blue
reminded him of natural forces that
constantly reshape the earth destroying
information so lou then mentioned the
moon
and the lack of
these forces and processes making it a
candidate to preserve something is it
loose belief that the moon shows
evidence that we are not the first
intelligent life to visit it
well certainly that's was was
part of nasa's curiosity and same with
with china now with their little rover
you know we're always looking for for
signs of
of something beyond us this is why we
are exploring the planets in our solar
system this is why we are looking for
techno signatures in our galaxy this is
why we send things out like the voyager
and the pioneer and these these space
probes out there
because we want to answer the
fundamental question are we alone
and um
you know certainly it makes sense if you
don't have the erosive forces like you
have here and the
the ever-changing environment whether
it's through tectonic movement or
through
water wind rain all the things that
grind mountains down to to to deserts
right those are very powerful forces
you know you you if you wanted to make
something last forever there's a few
ways to do it but you got to kind of
think outside the box to do it you can't
you can't you can't
don't think about it from
using the if you
if you can paint with any palette then
you don't have to be stuck with a
palette that's in front of you you know
to paint and ignore the canvas quite
frankly
so um i i think certainly
you know we we need we look for
archaeological evidence
here in our own planet for for ancient
you know
human presence um
i think we're doing that now with with
nasa that's what these rovers are for
and don't be surprised
if at some point in the future we you
know we substantiate that you know there
there was intelligent life perhaps
in on on other planets and moons and and
whatnot and it's may not just be
here we know that mars had an atmosphere
we know that it had a it had a
geomagnetic field around it protecting
its atmosphere at one point we know that
there was water on the atmosphere now
does that mean all life is sustained by
water no it doesn't maybe here on this
planet but
we do know that that amino acids have
been carried in from from meteors
uh coming into into our atmosphere and
our planet amino acids being the
building blocks for for life so
you know i i think i think we shouldn't
be surprised if at some point we have
that confirmation that that a lot of
people speculate you know
maybe there
okay sean do you have anything to add to
that
no i thought that was pretty succinct
colonel corn asks is there anything
about our moon that we should know about
that we don't know
everything we do
exactly
i'm not going to get my hackles up but
i'm going to say this a lot of these
questions
they're assumptive
there's a lot of people here that want
that sound like they're trying to prove
a line of thought that they're
interested in and i understand that but
a question like
what do we what do we need to know about
the moon that we don't know my answer is
everything that we don't know next
question exactly exactly everything
everything that we don't know
webstar rises asks do we have a direct
dna lineage with the others
it's fun to speculate but i i've got
i've got zero evidence either way uh
what we do know is that we have a lot in
common with uh not only a chimpanzee but
a banana you know so
uh what does that tell you right there's
a lot of commonality in our lineage
it's about all we can say right now
adam x asks in a recent interview lou
stated that he just finished a trip to
washington and that quote-unquote crap
is going to hit the fan soon can he
elaborate on this at all what does that
mean
yeah um
there's a lot happening
there's a lot happening
um
the conversation has definitely shifted
and more information is becoming
available
on a almost on a regular basis
um i'm not prepared to go into any type
of specifics right now um it will become
evident
uh i if there's one thing that's
hopefully been clear to people every
time i say the conversation's gonna
shift
and and new stuff comes out it it does i
i don't say that because the last thing
i want to do is over promise and under
deliver i'd rather under promise and
over deliver
um but
but the conversation is occurring
um
and
that's about all i can say right now for
that because it would require other
people to step in and comment that i'm
not at i do not i'm not
in a privileged situation where i can
share their
their comments or opinions on it um
what do you think i don't i got to be
careful i say
no i i
you know
lou and i go on podcast because we want
to we want to communicate we want to be
involved in a conversation
but especially in this instance we need
people to understand that when we have
something to say that's when we're going
to have something to say we're not in
the in the podcast business and we're
not we're not professional interviewers
and and frankly every time we do
podcasts it takes us away from the work
that makes the progress
now that doesn't and a lot of people
have wanted us you know they say we want
you guys to get more involved we need we
need answers well we don't have the
answers that you desire
we have we have
information that we have accrued we have
relationships we have accrued we have
things we're trying to change we have a
world we're trying to change but at this
point
it's becoming less and less
valuable for us to spend our time doing
these things when there's so much more
that we can be doing on in what people
call behind the scenes outside of
ufology away from from the public eye of
this
and i just want to say that people have
to ask themselves what they want
do they want to be entertained or do
they want change
it it is truly that simple because
we don't have and and this is not a
this is not me striking out but we don't
have time to entertain folks we don't
have time a lot of these questions
i'm not i understand they're interesting
questions they're questions i ask myself
but but for the time we have today
they're not and and for the work that we
work on they're not valuable they're not
additive at the moment to the work that
we're doing they end up muddying the
water a great deal because what we're
dipping into is a lot of questions about
various books and beliefs and ideas and
ufology
not what's on the record as evidentiary
value
and i i really want to stop i want to
stop asking or answering questions about
what do you think of so-and-so's book
where he had an idea
i don't think much of it it's his idea
it's and and i could say that for a
hundred other folks
because it's
it's not the we lou and i can't afford
to sit around the campfire and have a
just speculative conversation because
frankly people assign meaning to our
opinions that's i'm tired of that
and so i i want to see a place where we
can have a conversation that is additive
i know people want to know what we think
it's not important what sean cahill
thinks
okay it's not important what my opinions
are because i think my opinions are
garbage
it's important what your opinions are at
home i um i try to distance myself from
from from that current as much as
possible
um you know there's so much speculation
in this field and everybody pushes it
off as fact
um it's one of the reasons why you just
don't engage
you know i'm getting to the point i'll
tell you right now
i'm going to start doing a lot less
you're going to notice a huge i'm going
to do a few more to finish up my
obligations but
i'm not doing these much longer
this is it
reason is because
i'm not sure i'm being very helpful at
this point um i'm helpful behind the
scenes but
being like this in public all it does is
serve to divide people when really my
intent was to unite people bring them
together
but the the
i don't have time to focus
on the he said she said [ __ ] i don't
i don't care about it never have i never
will and you know you you you want more
of the same then go back to the last 70
years of [ __ ] because that's what
people think you are they think you're
full of [ __ ] because you talk about
wacky stuff you've got no evidence and
because he said he wrote a book on
something who you know
what does that mean means nothing you
got to show evidence you got you got to
you know where the bona fides where are
the videos where's the reports where's
the the the discussions to congress and
the classified briefings
they're nowhere because i haven't seen
them on the hill when i'm there i
haven't seen them in dc when i'm going
by the pentagon or anywhere else they're
not those meetings so for me to come out
and when i you know historically i've
always tried to share information to be
as transparent as possible
but i think we're reaching a point now
where
i think people have what they need kurt
i i don't think they need lou elizondo
coming in and feeding them
information anymore um you know and if
and if they want to go back to the way
you followed you wasn't young he'll be
my guest i'm not stopping you yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] you know that's on you
you know but you're not gonna stop me
from doing my pursuits because i'm
taking this very seriously and i think
you know i was when i first came into
this people told me oh ufology eats its
own i'm like what the hell is ufology i
don't even know what that is i'm not a
ufologist i never have but i never will
be so stop wrapping me into that i'm not
i am not into a ufology i'm not in fact
it was up to me i'd blow it up into a
million pieces of i said before and
hopefully what coalesce would be
something far more scientific far more
objective i don't know man i i want us
to to build to be additive and i and
people keep calling me and going
can you prove this can you prove that
can you prove this and it's like we
already did
we already did
every week it's the same crap
and and so
i want to know why that's the thing that
ufology ufology itself is so interested
why do they want to know what's in my
garbage why do i have to make my fence
taller and putting cameras at my house
why am i getting people knocking on my
door thinking i have secrets i don't
have their secrets man
and and that's something i don't think
people understand
this isn't a movie it's not we we may be
seen as larger than life by other people
but i'm this size
you know what i'm you know i get up in
the morning i do all the same things we
all do i feel like crap
you know and and i should exercise more
and eat better and i don't i'm a real
person i'm not a figure
that's that's something the public does
themselves
i'm not a i'm not even a subject matter
expert i'll go out on a limb and say
that myself
because we don't have an established
curriculum in this we choose our subject
matter experts by by
by the how they perform
and so far ufology has chosen subject
matter experts that make them feel good
tell them the story that fits their
memory their experience their favorite
flavor their favorite story and all of
the research that i've done i can't find
one person out there that i would go
let's get them on board they can help us
there's so because everybody i talk to
goes
it's the zetas right i'm like man no
there's i don't know i don't know what a
zeta is
i i got a book at home with
175
different alien species listed out in it
and it's sponsored by mufon
and and it's the most ridiculous bunch
of science fiction i've ever seen in my
life and i'm like why did no fun put
their name on this those are i know
mufon people as individuals
caring pragmatic dedicated
investigators some of them are amateurs
some of them are professionals again
like us own money own time own effort
why would they expose themselves
to zeb's cornucopia of alien jackasses
i i i don't get it
how do we how do we break off from the
nonsense because i can't do it anymore i
know lou can't do it anymore
so that's my
i would throw that question back to you
and your and your in your and your your
audience
how do we change this
let me see if i understand this because
i don't want there to be
a
misunderstanding by the people who are
watching you're not upset at the people
who are asking questions nor are you
upset at me nor are you unreal no no no
no we're not even upset
yeah more about that the types of
questions indicate that the ufo
community at large is either misguided
or misled and there are opportunity
costs as well so they could be focusing
on something that you feel like is more
productive let me if i can reiterate uh
this is not the frustration by sean and
i are is definitely not directed towards
you or anybody in your audience or the
person asking the question they're
legitimate and they're good questions
what we are frustrated with
is is the
habitual tendency
to go back and discuss things
that are not only not relevant but have
been implanted as falsehoods to begin
with
by
people in the past and and these these
things continue to resurface well okay
that's fine lou we're we're talking
about potentially uh you know another
incident from an f-35 but but what about
the reptilians what does it have to do
with reptilians guys
we're not talking about reptilians man i
mean
stop please
try try your best to to remove whatever
you may have learned in the past about
this and say well i've been researching
this for 30 years you know what you've
been researching fiction
so a lot of this stuff has been
fictionalized
you know you're not an expert in reading
someone else's book that doesn't make
you an expert i'm sorry
and so you've you've gotta you've gotta
learn to approach this a little bit more
objectively and this is why we are
loathsome to offer our position and
perspective because at the end of the
day i don't to be guilty of the same
thing it doesn't matter what lou
elizondo thinks it doesn't matter what
sean thinks it matters what you think
here's the data here's the facts you
figured out for yourself what this means
to you what to your religion your
culture your philosophy your psychology
sociology and everything else in between
how how you identify with this
information is up to you it's not my job
to tell you what to think about my job
is simply to provide you the information
the evidence and you figure it out for
yourself and your family and your
friends and however else you want to do
it but don't superimpose that on me
please don't do that i don't do that on
you please don't do that to me because
it's not fair and it's
i think it's a distraction to the bigger
conversation we're having i cannot
every time i look at social media i am
blown away
at how people behave and treat each
other and and the self delusion i mean i
have people that are making up entire
conversations they've had with me that
i've never i've never spoken to the
person in my life and they're going
around and it's it's not healthy
and then those require numerous tweets
and back pedaling and it's it seems like
that's the that's the desire
of certain folks is to make sure just
like a lot of folks would observe in our
own society that if you create enough
chaos it creates a system that you can
exploit and that will be
self-perpetuating
and at this point and kurt and i'm not
i'm not accusing you of this i'm not
accusing your audience of it i'm just
i'm just taking a chance at this point
just hit the bathroom real quick by the
way go ahead i'm not checking out but i
got i gotta use the bathroom this is
this has been really tough for us
because
it's it's a tough decision to decide
whether or not to participate
at the level that folks want because we
want we want to keep talking to
everybody you know what i mean but
i'm not getting any work done when i do
this
so i'm not attacking you guys your
audience man no we can i don't feel
attacked i just i i have a feeling some
people would think you were attacking so
i want to clear the air
a lot of people are triggered very
easily a lot of people get very offended
when they don't hear what they want i'll
be i'll come out and say that people in
our community our larger community have
some pretty skewed expectations
they have a very
they have an immense lack of those who
didn't serve in the military have no
clue what it's like those who haven't
worked in government service have no
clue what it's like
i had somebody recently asked me do you
have any any pay stubs that say you did
the following i'm like man my pay stubs
say usn for the last 20 years i was in
the united states navy they never said
chief petty officer or interrogator or
or or you know police officer and we
spend a lot of time answering dumb
questions like that people don't even
know what they're talking about i'm
going to put it just like that i'm not
talking about your audience i'm just
taking a chance to say why we're
frustrated with some stuff
because i would love i mean we talked
about having a couple of beers and
having a having a groovy you know kind
of esoteric conversation
but i gotta say that the way that some
of these have been formed is
i don't believe in gotcha questions
there's there aren't gotcha questions
there's gotcha there's people that get
got
and don't take the time to answer a
question utilizing their acronym or
there's or there's people that you know
that take their time through it but are
they useful
and we're just encountering so much
non-additive
um interaction at this point because
we're saturated saturated with
interviewers saturated with you know
with questions and stuff
and so
for me that i just want to get across to
people that we're we're willing to work
as hard as possible
but
it's
at some point we have to decide whether
our work the work that we're doing
is is um
is additive that's the word that i use
most often
and kurt i'll tell you too if i if i can
you know be very mindful um
that
even even yourself right you have we're
doing this show right now we're talking
to you and your audience and
there are people that are trying to
sabotage or or hijack this conversation
use this conversation we're having with
you
to
push their own agenda and their own
narrative
right now you're seeing it live on your
on your on your your chat people that
have ulterior motives and agendas and
are looking to construe and misconstrue
information and
you know the very thing that we are
against you're witnessing it right now
it's happening right now
as you and i are having this
conversation
and and it's happening because people
are taking advantage of
of this
to to to push a narrative or an agenda
and i think that's disappointing um i
think it's exactly what what what sean
and i and others are opposed to who take
this topic very seriously we're not
trying to create a jerry springer
environment and sadly as it is you're
witnessing the very thing that we're
against happening right now right now on
your chat room as we speak
um
and that's you know that's this goes
exactly to the point i'm trying to make
you know people aren't interested in
in a discussion they're interested in
drama they're interested in the soap
opera
and
i don't want to be involved in that you
know you want to do that be that but
i've got more important [ __ ] to do than
than to be part of that
that he said she said crap
that's that's not what i'm interested in
and if that's what other people are
interested then you know spend your time
doing that but please don't waste my
time because i'm i'm i'm not into that
i've got i've got far more important
priorities on my plate than to than to
you know jump into a
virtual mosh pit right with with people
who aren't interested in really
doing anything accomplishing anything
all they want to do is sling mud
and
you know i mean that's that's certainly
the right and privilege if they want to
do that but
don't involve me i'm not interested in
that you know i'm interested in real
discussion elevated conversation um
treating people with dignity and respect
not the
you know the the dog pile that we're
we're seeing it unfortunately this topic
seems to bring out the best and and and
in some cases the worst of individuals
we we beat that horse to death i mean i
i know that i'm the one that led it into
the stable but
uh let's move yeah let's go ahead chris
okay so how about this question which
well hopefully it's a question that you
all don't dislike intensely
it's ratio ratio asks this question kurt
what is the environment that they refer
to when they're saying that they created
it to attract the phenomenon remember
earlier when we were talking about
communication yeah that's a great
question no um
you know i'll answer this generally i
think a lot of people already kind of
know what i'm kind of what i'm alluding
to but we've known that there's been
been interesting um correlations between
nuclear
technology capabilities what not
and and uap activity so clearly if you
can create an environment
where
you can potentially attract these things
then you can probably collect more data
on these things and so
you know there lies
part of the key if you can create a
situation where maybe you these things
come because they're interested in what
you have
then you can you can collect information
um that's about about much as i'm
prepared to say right now but i think a
lot of people kind of know historically
if you look at uh robert hastings book
um
the the nukes and ufos um
you know it's
there's a lot of compelling data in
there
sean you have anything to add to that
i mean i'll throw some some uh
some redneck metaphors out there and say
you don't go to alabama to catch a
hippopotamus
i see
yes nick d says over the time frame that
you researched and investigated uaps did
you see the uaps improve like faster
speeds more daring maneuvers
capabilities over time
in other words
is there evidence that their technology
has advanced
it's it's one of those it assumes that i
have observed you know it assumes a lot
but um nope
not in my lifetime
i can't even say what their technology
truly does
so it's a hard question to answer
yeah same to me or with me i haven't i
haven't seen any
any any indicators that their technology
has has changed or necessarily improved
a lot of the the observations we see now
are the same ones that were made in the
in quite frankly in the 60s and even the
50s
blaine tortorian asks in the gq
interview lou you mentioned that a pilot
experienced 30 minutes go by on his
watch but only consumed five minutes of
fuel in his jet did you happen to find
any corroborating evidence in the form
of few log discrepancies or
chronographic anomalies on the jet any
tips for forming a foia request on this
yeah there's there's actually been been
several
experiences like that reported by by
eyewitnesses uh military sources
there's one very compelling i won't say
the person's name um but he was on a
mountaintop
and um
felt like just a few minutes went by and
uh five hours had gone by
you know this is the whole missing time
right uh peop the observation that some
people report to have that
that uh what appeared to be just a few
minutes in reality was much much longer
and there's also a lot of reporting from
foreign pilots as well and foreign uh
military personnel so this isn't just a
u.s thing there's other individuals who
have have experiences as well the
problem is very hard to reconcile um
because you know at some point
human observation is subjective you know
and
i think i think we have to be careful i
think it's a data point but as sean
likes to say all the time at the end of
the day it's just a data point
um
you know it we
it's in the collection of many many data
points that allows us to create a much
more comprehensive picture
so i'm always careful not to just use a
single data point and that's why from
the percep perspective of atip the
observables were so important because
you had five distinct actually six
distinct observables that when put
together painted a very compelling
picture you know one could say well we
have hypersonic vehicles or we have
vehicles that can do
instantaneous acceleration or low
observability
but we don't have one that can do all
five right and so that's when it becomes
very compelling and the same thing with
the with the biological effects in this
case if you have missing time then then
that is potentially a biological or a
psychological effect and that's
something that you now see in the in the
law you know we have to we have to
report on biological effects
recently this is a question that i have
george knapp revealed that area 51 has a
multitude of names like paradise ranch
and the ranch and red square i wrote a
couple of them else down saint elsewhere
home plate homie airport the site so
have you heard of these and can this
information be used for a foia request
kurt i lost you entirely here for some
reason my my my headphone went out for a
second can you repeat that again worst
comes to worst happens again i'll switch
to these these ugly things
george knapp revealed that area 51 has
many names paradise ranch
the ranch red square home plate etc have
you heard of these i assume that these
were governmental names so i'm curious
if this information if it can be used
for a foia request
and also why do you think it has so many
names does it mean that there are
multiple government organizations
operating there
i think all information can be used for
foia
you know we have we have names for new
york we call it the big city we call it
the big apple we call it all sorts of
things right
um you know organizations over time you
know give give names some of it's for
real reasons like opsec we call
operational security you know if you you
want to keep saying uh you know people
that were in the cia you know of course
i can say this but everybody was oh you
know
he's he went to the farm right the farm
is it's not really the name of it but
that's what you call it you know same
thing with area 51 or groom lake or you
know whatever non-destroyer you want to
use um
there's lots of reasons why people do
that
some of it again is for true operational
reasons because you don't want to use
something's real name and you want to
use it in conversation and somebody
who's also right on to something you can
you let's say kurt you and sean and i
were part of a program and you can't
ever say the program's name so you you
call it something else you know hey we
got to go talk about the elephant
tomorrow and elephant being you know a
code word for the program right and so
those are the type of things that that
are that are quite common especially in
the military when you're talking about
military facilities and organizations
it's super super common you know um
like for example when i was in in in in
the army in uh
in um in korea south korea uh you you
know we have it uh you have the second
id the second infantry division up on
the dmz but we called it the deuce you
know was it that its official name no
but everybody referred to it as the
deuce
um it's it's it's quite common sean you
gotta any i'd say boil what you like and
see what you get back i mean
i would ask them if they have any
interest in what area one through fifth
through 57 are called as well because
all of those test ranges exist too
i mean i don't know what the exact
number is
but area five one was not picked out of
nowhere it's a it's a grid marker
so
and it's is it a test facility it would
seem that that's been acknowledged
during bill clinton's administration
aerial photos where the first you know
came out for the first time and that's
how we got into the idea that area 51
was even a real place
and that it was a test range
but past that i can't i don't know i
appreciate george's work don't get me
wrong i would never in a million years
down anything george is incredible he is
an edifice to this subject he is one of
the most valuable intellects and and
archives and has some of the best
understanding of anyone around here so i
think that if george knapp found a bunch
of names that were associated with with
the nevada test site
if you are into foia i think that's a
good person to look to to find keywords
but but beyond that i don't know what
area 51 does beyond test aircraft at for
nellis air force base
and yes i know that there are certain
terminals and airlines and all these
other things that like to go back and
forth but again stories
i don't have proof if i had proof i'd be
on i'd call you up and we'd have a
really cool show if i was like look bro
i got proof
you know and so i won't talk about it
like i have proof until i have proof
okay this question comes from cyprian
sigonic
among all the uap incidents you've
investigated
which one stands out to you
for me it's the 2004 nimitz tic tac
incident because we have the most
comprehensive
um multi-spectral data on it now do we
have access to all of that note
but we at least have the rational
stories or excuse me anecdotes and and a
certain paper trail to follow that says
that those tapes were taken
and so
the first thing that says to me is in
2004 there was a program running that
was ready to respond to incidences like
this at least to debrief and retrieve
elint data
but that's that's all i know but to me
that's the most interesting because we
can nail down the most
the most comprehensive pieces of an
investigation something worthwhile
occurred and that there's more
information out there that we can
that we could get on it we could clarify
if we had that information we would know
a lot more
and it's multi you know i say
multi-spectral i want to be careful when
i say that i'm saying multi-point
multi-point
so to me that's the most interesting one
and granted i was there i don't think my
eyewitness account is the most
interesting thing of it i think it's way
towards the bottom of the list it's it's
completely unprovable
um
but beyond that that's my one i'd be
interested to hear what it has to say
uh i said before it's like choosing my
favorite kid right um
i love them all i find something
interesting in every single of the
incidents that i've been privy to um
some are very very compelling some are a
bit more anecdotal some are
you know as i've said before i i can't
provide more than other than saying
there's a 23 minute video that's really
really really compelling
um you know
those are the ones that leave you really
scratching your head saying
what the hell did i just see
um
you know might my hope is that ascendant
some of these incidents become more and
more um
prevalent and and people in in office
particularly congress are successful in
getting some of this stuff declassified
that some of the more compelling
videos and incidents will become more
public public knowledge and then and
then you can have that conversation
right then i can ask you
the same question what which one is your
most compelling incident right now there
there
there's there's so many of them and
there someone were just
truly baffling um
but you know unfortunately there's
there's well most of it i really can't
can't talk about yet in the public
sphere
which for me is very frustrating sure
which one stands out that you can talk
about would it be the nimitz as well
well the nimitz was certainly one of the
most comprehensive investigations that
thing went on for a while there were
several investigations there's a lot of
documentation reporting on it a lot of
it was made public
um i think it's you know it's it's
certainly one of the gold standards for
for the us government as far as
investigations um but there's
there's a lot more i mean
chris will tell you the story about him
seeing an email um
from somebody this very senior ranking
person in the navy basically saying i
got these things all over my ship what
do you want me to do
you know i can't keep people below deck
forever i mean
people are going to see these things how
do you want me to to what do you want
what do you want me to do about this
right because i i'm
they're they're
it's very prevalent and and this is
going to be this won't be able to be
kept secret for very long so
you know that's an example of of of just
sheer frustration in some cases you're
like you know
we've got to get a handle on this we
really do we got to we got to figure
this out
this is about the ocean casey price
wants to know regarding uso so
unidentified submerged objects
have you seen underwater photographs or
video that support that they exist
well first of all photographic evidence
underwater is a much different story
than photographic evidence in the sky
okay
first of all water is opaque water is
very dense light doesn't travel very
well
in fact uh in a very close crystal i'm
an avid scuba diver on a crystal clear
day in some of the best caribbean waters
in the world your visibility is maybe
120 feet if you're lucky and that's not
really that far if you think about it
you know it is when you're diving but
but
it's not really that far and so so we
have to rely on other technical means to
to to if you will see virtually
underwater we use things like sonar we
use very much like we talked about
earlier uh the same principles that that
dolphins use to echolocate we do that as
well using submarines and ships and we
can see below the water virtually right
we're not actually seeing but we're we
are creating an image a virtual image
that allows us you know to to see the
bottom of the ocean and what's in
between whether it's through side
scanning sonar or or other means um the
problem is that
sound also travels only at a certain
speed underwater so you're only going to
sonar can only pick up and be used to to
pick up objects
um that are going at least as fast or
slower than the sonar
signals otherwise it outruns it right
and you never you never catch up
so there's limitations um and that's why
you have the quote unquote silent
service of submarines why they're so
stealthy because you know here you have
basically
something the size of this you know
skyscraper underwater that no one ever
sees because it's hard to see underwater
now does that mean we have technical
data um you know beyond just you know
images for example what you might see in
the water yeah there seems to be some
pretty compelling information down there
to suggest that
that uap may also be related to usos um
and that the two may in fact be very
very relate very much related and that
objects that are flying in and around
our skies while flying that's not really
the right term but in in and around our
atmosphere may also have the ability to
perform uh
similarly underwater and this is where
the trans-medium travel piece comes into
as far as the five observables things
that have the ability to fly with the
same performance characteristics in our
atmosphere as they can underwater and
possibly even in space
you know we we do have technologies that
are trans medium we have
for example a seaplane you know seaplane
can fly and it can also float on the
water but let's face it a seaplane isn't
really a good aircraft or a really good
boat it's a compromise because in order
to operate in more domains or more more
environments you have to you have to
accommodate more things more
considerations and there's always
sacrifices performance sacrifices
associated with that um and that's why
you would never expect a sea plane to to
fly like an f-22 or or operate like a uh
like a submarine
because it just can't it's just just too
much and yet that's precisely what we're
seeing here in some cases with with
these uap
in the navy we have a term called
scuttlebutt
and it's something that in general the
leadership tries to cut down on
scuttlebutt
but it's rumor
um
and so what i'm about to give you a
scuttlebutt because i won't give you
names and i'm not going to help folks
and i won't even say what platforms i
talk to folks from because you could
easily trace folks not you i'm not
saying you would either i'm just not
gonna one get them talking yeah
but i've talked to my um
numerous
senior uh enlisted leaders sonar tech
sonar technicians
and it's practically you know they'll
look left they'll look right and they'll
be like that's an open secret
we all know there are usos we all know
there are things that are we're picking
up on sonar just like your radar texts
are like yeah we've all seen your phones
you don't talk about it you just keep
you know you talk about the aircraft in
your pattern make sure there's no safety
violations and everybody laughs it off
and
you know some people don't even make log
entries the sonar techs are going
through the same thing so i'll throw
that it's scuttlebutt i can you know i
can't verify it i'm not going to haul
any of them up here on the show for you
and they already told me they don't want
to get involved they got their they got
their own jobs they're not willing to
risk any of it for the stuff but the
word on the street is it's an open
secret
and what a couple of the guys have told
me is we're told to log it and dog it
what that means is
in some cases in the old days and then
you put it in the the log and then you
lined it out
so it was no longer an official entry
um in this case it is morphed into don't
even write it down
because they're not going to do anything
about it now
that's as i said that's scuttlebutt
that's rumor
but i've collected that from numerous
disparate sources so
more than that it's it's it that's
that's that's very accurate what sean is
telling you um and there was a i can say
there was because there's an article on
it um about the navy's what they call
that people are familiar with with the
with the fast walker program but i'm not
sure people are familiar so much with
the fast mover program and that was an
article if anybody cares to look it up
you can look it up
um you know it's it's about about the
navy's uh
um
collection of data regarding you know
incidentally of of usos
and i'll include a link to that in the
description so for those who are
watching or listening you can check out
the description for that so brian asks
how important is sound to the advanced
physics theories about the uaps now this
is interesting because usually we hear
about gravity light and so on have you
heard anything about sound being
essential rather than simply in fact
i'll jump on that my one of my
colleagues chris mellon is working very
hard right now um trying to to acquire
data from uh infrasonics um you know
think entering the earth's atmosphere um
give off an acoustic signature uh
whether it's an asteroid or meteor or
you know ballistic missile per se um
everything has signatures an aircraft
you can sit in your backyard look at an
airplane going over and you can hear the
jet engine
there are acoustic signatures associated
with these things and infrasonics is is
part of that and as chris suggested in
his recent most recent article that
there is data available potentially that
could help us better understand the
nature of uaps
if we had the ability to to
access that data and if we knew what we
were looking for so so yeah it's a great
question and it's something that that is
being looked into
speaking of accessible data this
question comes from rebecca schwart
thank you to all three of you for your
time question are you aware of any
civilian-based data collection slash
analysis efforts worth looking into
further what civilian accessible data
would you advise collecting
at the moment i would first point to uh
dr avilo
his efforts being done at
uh at the galileo project uh beyond that
i'm not prepared to say any names out
there i do have some some uh
some colleagues that we've worked with
that we've helped advise on a certain on
a couple of projects that are interested
in data collection uh collating that
data and
providing it uh as needed
um
i don't think we could have enough data
collection
in while while you'll hear me talk about
too many podcasts we need more data
collection companies
we need more people that are going to
attack the electromagnetic spectrum from
every every possible
you know vantage point that they can and
then think of other means to sample our
reality for
replicatable or at least recordable data
um
so that the folks i i'm not i'm i don't
push other people's businesses and you
know i don't i don't do that but um but
there are people working very hard that
have come very far that have made a lot
of relationships and have built an
infrastructure in the last couple years
because they were paying attention and i
really look forward to seeing what they
have to offer soon there's a question
here from joe mergia and he has a
podcast called ufo gel which i'll link
in the description have you come across
any information that you deem credible
that holloman was a real event now the
claims for those who are unfamiliar is
that a craft of unknown origin landed at
holloman af base in 1964 humanoid
looking beans got out and were whisked
away off to a meeting with the military
brass at the base then left so what's
your opinion on the aspects of these
claims
i've read the same stories everyone else
has read in ufology
um you know i'll tell you that that
the problem is we don't know what's been
what is based in a real event and then
what has been
added to a story right so
usually a lot of stories are based in in
some fact the question is how much fact
right
did something happen
uh at holloman air force base and if so
what and uh did all these other things
that happened later
you know is it just a story that grew
and grew and grew and grew and
snowballed into what we know what we
what we hear now
or was it all based in in truth or
partial truth and so you know that's
that's something that is
trying to be determined
um that you know the problems with these
cold cases is that the longer the time
goes on
the harder it gets this is you know 50
years ago and most of the people if any
would be involved in that may be dead by
now
so it's hard and so that's why in a tip
we really were focusing on the here and
now if you will on on incidents
involving involving
military equities
now or in the present because going back
to these
it's it you almost don't know where to
start right because it's it's kind of
gone it's gone now into into the world
of mythology where
you know people say certain things but i
heard it through this person who heard
it through that person who was someone
who was stationed there who saw the
video who saw that
it's hard and so i'm not going to
comment on that simply because hey i
wasn't there and i don't know
but i will say that it is certainly
interesting and and you know obviously
we keep our feelers out for anybody who
wants to come forward who may have
additional information regarding that
event if they want to share it we'd love
to hear it
okay this question is from andy from
that ufo podcast thanks to the three of
you and what more needs to be done to
encourage those in the mainstream to get
involved with data collection
hello so we'll start with sean
well that's frankly that's what i'm
working on every day it's um it's
cutting the nonsense we've been frankly
complaining and borderline ranting about
on this on this podcast cutting it out
not entertaining it anymore
um not even frankly i don't care go
start your own show
you know what i mean um you want to find
out all the secrets of the various
universe go for it we want to collect
data
and so we talk to people we as i as i
often say we say this is real
here are some excellent data points to
look at
what are your thoughts do you see merit
here they say yes i see merit would you
like to help us collect more data and
try to understand this these are i mean
i'm presenting this in a very vague
fashion
but it's that simple
hey can i have your attention
this is real would you like to get
involved yes you know yes or no some
people have said no
they said you know what we've already
we're already in a good place we have
good contracts here we're in a place
like this we don't want to mess with our
you know we don't want to spook our
clientele or our investors or or
whatever it is
and it's understandable but some people
see this for what it is
that for some something's different i
don't i don't i've never liked the
question why now i don't know
now i'm i only have now as i said
earlier in our conversation
um
but it's interesting
um and so i you know i i hope that's
nice
lou
yeah can you um
i want to be accurate as possible can
you repeat the question please um
you want to know what people could do to
uh to encourage data collection in the
private sector
at a higher level
[Applause]
i mean it's a tough question because i
mean
i would say anything people can do is is
helpful but then again
that's not entirely true every time
because
not everything is helpful
um
you know i i think
i think being aware of the conversation
um you know everybody now has one of
these devices in their hands right so
you're you're a virtual collection
platform taking videos pictures and
whatnot
um
i think being informed um arming
yourself with knowledge and information
um and yes that it may seem
contradictory but it requires um
talking to people you know and and by
the way formulating your own opinions as
a result of that okay don't don't take
somebody else's opinions
um and understanding the the playing
field you know who who who's legitimate
who's not what are the motivations and
and
by by certain organizations and people
that may be involved in this topic why
do some people
have the opinions that they do you know
uh
maybe
you know it it's hard for me to say
because
you're asking people to teach themselves
and they say okay well teach me how to
teach myself well
then again if i do that then it would
fall into the same you know pit we did
last time while teaching you what to
think and not how to think and so
um i don't want to be overly
prescriptive just be curious be yourself
ask the questions
it's okay to ask the questions um
i think uh
be fearless in your pursuit of knowledge
and and also have the courage to
question
um
question people including myself
including sean including you including
everybody
um
questions aren't bad um questioning is
is good now uh
disrespect and attacks now that's that's
not um you know that's that's not that's
not ever
something that should be should be
supported or condoned
sadly it is
if you're going to ask somebody a
question about their opinion make damn
sure you know what yours is first and be
willing to state it and stand behind it
and be willing to change it if the other
person's opinion and their data change
is yours
but holding an opinion asking questions
and i'm not talking about you again kurt
i'm just saying a lot of times in this
field it's so combative
that people wield questions like swords
and and and
use petty excuses for shields
um
it's important that we all have a good
understanding we want to have a
conversation
we don't want to have an interrogation
session
we want to have a you know a
a a conversation where we're all
educated enough to bring the
conversation to a new level to rise to
something new and to create something
new and so that's why a lot of times we
yeah again we get posed a lot of
questions that i'm not sure if the if
the question person asking it
already expects a specific answer
or or is looking to learn i guess so i
would also say be prepared to challenge
the hucksters and the fraudsters and the
liars you know when when someone is is
spewing off their opinion and they've
been confirmed to be a liar and lied
about things in the past
then you know hold them accountable say
hey you know you said this before and
you got caught lying
uh or or deceiving or not telling the
truth why should we believe you now
right there's people out there
pretending they're spies
there's people out there recording
private conversations there's people out
there making up conversations and
claiming
data that's so far beyond the pale it's
ridiculous and they're doing all of it
to maintain some kind of
attention
return on investment that they need
and
i just don't understand it and there's
we have a whole community that
has this passive aggressive conversation
on the undertone about who's doing what
who's who in the zoo and who's treating
people poorly
and then everybody turns around they go
hey bob so good to be back on the show
again and and what's new this week and
it's because everybody's afraid of their
reputation everybody's afraid you know
they're all looking in their own they're
looking at each all their neighbors
bowls to see what they have in them
instead of worrying about what's in
their own bowl
and it gets tiresome i'm sorry this
keeps coming up but it's
there's no accountability you know it's
it's um
it's it's it's it's a situation where
you have people who are are
self-proclaimed experts and qualified
experts when they're certainly not
uh and and who have been been shown in
the past to to
to to be frauds and uh
you know no one holds them accountable
um they then they continue to sow
dissension and discord uh throughout the
community and there's there's not
there's not a whole lot of them but
there's a few of these agent
provocateurs
and they're they're not held accountable
and they're allowed to continue to spew
their vile and their misinformation and
and tarnish the reputation of people who
really are engaged in this topic in a
very serious manner and i think that's a
problem i think until those people are
held accountable
we're going to continue to have this
situation that we have now
it's because people willing to kind of
turn a blind eye and say well
okay let's get it well at some point you
know people when they wonder why don't
people take this topic seriously you
gotta look in the mirror at some point
you gotta say hey you know maybe
maybe you're the problem maybe i'm the
problem right and um
it's it's hard to do you gotta but but
holding people accountable and holding
yourself accountable
is i think very very important you know
every time i make a mistake i try the
first time someone brings it up to me
and i try to get online hey guys listen
i i i made a mistake you know let me let
me clarify our caveat um
we've got to hold ourselves accountable
and i almost guarantee you if i can that
that that somewhere whether today or
tomorrow or in the chat or whatever
someone's going to say well why don't
you just name the names think look i'm
not here to hold people account
i'm here to advance the conversation i
don't if i start if you want me to hold
people accountable cool we'll put the
whole conversation on hold while i go
into a freaking legal slog for the next
10 years of my life holding those people
accountable all by my damn self
okay
the audience needs to hold each other
accountable self policing our peers is
the fir is the first part of of our of
our
society
i mean come on even in the navy that i i
was i was a master and i was a law
enforcement officer onboard a ship why
did we need a law enforcement officer we
had a leadership structure they should
have been taking care of all these
things
but in the end of the day we're all just
humans we need we need police
unfortunately at some level whole
another societal argument i don't want
to kill that crap off but
um i just think we can
what we're talking about here is is look
there's pete there's you don't need your
subject matter experts to be generalists
you don't need your generalists to get
mired in the minutia of the data they
need to trust the the experts
and and in this case too we need to look
to each other and go is this what we
want
is this the community that we want to
maintain or can we take a break from the
constant daily drip
can we wait for things to develop and
can we start figuring out outside of the
subject matter experts that we've
appointed how do we feel about this what
do we really believe what are our
answers to these questions what do we
think about holloman have we looked into
it does it look like nonsense or not the
next person who tells me you know the
moon's hollow oh my god i i'm just like
could you could you start somewhere else
with me besides hey did you know the
moon is hollow
you know teach to show me that you've
done your research and and we don't have
a baseline for that
so
yeah
let me jump in here too let me give you
a real case scenario about holding
ourselves accountable okay
um
i don't have your chat on here but you
know you ask
perfection point you ask sean and i to
come on and and drink a beer for your
show okay um so i thought it'd be fun to
grab this now what you don't know in
your audience doesn't know that last
night i emptied this out
and i fill this with apple juice right
so no i'm not going to drink on your
show but if it helps the conversation
everybody get going to be fun yeah sure
go ahead i'll put a beer bottle in bin
but it was filled with apple juice that
god's honest truth and of course what do
people people start accusing instantly
oh these guys are toasted they're
sloshed this is my point
people are are so used to coming out
and just spewing crap
when they don't know they have no clue
and they they spew it out as facts and
then other people pick it up say oh that
must be right mother they're toasted you
know what i have zero percent alcohol in
my body right now zero i've been
drinking coffee most of the time and
apple juice
this is my point the problem with
ufology
and all these people out there that
supposedly know [ __ ] they don't know
anything and now of course oh look at
louise yawning and he's he must be drunk
or toasted
i am stone ass cold sober and it's it's
this is
you know so here's my my case in point
and and of course they don't know her
that you had asked us to come on your
show and we'd all get relaxed and have a
beer right well
yeah okay sure it's a beer bottle but
i'm not drinking beer and so
that's this is this is again i this is
just a very small example of how
people who don't have all the
information will jump to a conclusion
as if they do have it and and then that
will pick up legs people pick it up and
say oh you think oh you're right oh my
gosh i want no part of that [ __ ] i want
no part of it that's exactly what is
wrong
with this community and i'm sorry i
don't want to be part of that i want to
be part of of logic and and rationale i
don't want to be part of speculation in
innuendos and i think or maybe or i'm
not interested in that and this is my
problem this is exactly why i'm
frustrated with it because it's a bunch
of rank ass amateurs that aren't helping
the conversation now if you really want
to help the conversation have the
conversation with us and stop
speculating and stop trying to provide
false narratives that aren't there and
they're not real well to me that's
entertainment and it's it's about time
we left that entertainment to the people
that want to entertain themselves
agree i agree you're right it's
entertaining i've experienced
like probably one percent of what you've
all experienced and it's already
it already hurts me i have a thin skin
i'm not like you well as i was joking
before i'm not a man like you all are
and so i've experienced
well i won't get into different details
it's not about it
or anything else and some people thought
that i planned what i said to linda
molten how as a gotcha question and then
they were saying well why don't you
interview other women i'm saying did you
not browse through the channel how about
mathuna how about merrell kindet how
about sabine haasenfelder or
rebecca goldstein and so on
and then i feel like oh and then i'm
justifying myself and then that makes it
worse because it gives
they don't see it as
as
they're not terribly interested in
um and i'm speaking extremely vaguely
when i say they because some people are
they actually just are questioning and
maybe they're just incorrect and maybe
they're passionate and and that's and
that's fine but some people
they want to get you and they probably
already have a reason to dislike you
well i'm also just speaking about myself
even though i'm using the word you
but anyway yeah you're pretty aware
i'm following i'm tracking continue
please yeah
no it's not a pleasant place to be i
don't like it and i
it affects me deeply it affects me a bit
too much like i get you and linda
to an extent being pushed from both
sides by an angry mob
there's an unfortunate aspect when you
reach a certain level of exposure
unless you're going gonna put some kind
of gestapo like filter on your on your
chats and things like that
you're gonna be exposed to people that
are gonna do things like that
and um
i'm gonna i'm gonna bust your chops for
saying you're not a man you're most
certainly a man don't don't do that to
yourself my friend
um
but beyond that
i'm going to tell you something when i'd
i'd rather have your thin skin because
mine's scarred over
i'm not i'm not
careless
i am i am i'm i'm beaten and bruised by
this stuff i've had friends of mine
people who are formerly my colleagues
and my friends try to hurt myself and my
family and dox me on the internet on
4chan and put my personal information
out there so my phone number is useless
if i want to keep it
and i'm i'm not going to write an
article about that man and i don't want
to talk about that for too long on this
show but i'm tired and i'm hurt
and i'm going to keep working i just may
not keep doing it on a camera
you know
and you've got you know at some point
you've got to ask yourself too all of us
do why are we doing this
and if i'm able to
if it turns out maybe i'm doing it for
the wrong reasons or the wrong people am
i able to tailor that back and still
maintain my own integrity i hope so
yeah
yeah it's something i think about plenty
and there's also this question that
sometimes people are an accusation more
than a question which is don't you have
a responsibility to do x
and usually those come from people who
don't have a large platform and they'll
say well look you have a large platform
so you have a responsibility to talk
about x or to not talk about why
and
that's so tricky
because who yeah who who determines my
responsibility
right right right there's that and
outside of something that's legal like a
signed document it's difficult to say
that you're responsible for something
although i do agree that most of the
time whenever anyone lays that upon me i
do think that i am responsible for most
of what they say i am responsible for
like i'm responsible
for putting out positive and
constructive information i don't think i
am and i think i'm failing in my
responsibility almost all of what they
say it's just that i don't know how to
live up to all of that and i also feel
like sometimes some people want me to
say yeah but this guest said so and so
and that's false and don't you want to
correct that and i would love actually
i'm thinking about putting in a
corrections segment to the introductions
of the videos
but also at the same time if i spent my
time constantly correcting i feel like
then someone would say aren't you
failing in your responsibility to
provide new information now
so there are opportunity costs
associated with the responsibility and
it's almost
i feel like every individual has
infinite responsibility so that's why i
feel like what they're saying is true
and i i just say that i'm failing at my
responsibility i don't know what else to
do about that other than to follow my
own curiosity and to try to be honest
and earnest and that's what i try to do
and that's why some of these questions
i'm asking you you see what's wrong with
them but for me i'm such a newcomer that
i'm like well what's a big deal about
this question i think about these
questions all the time so i'm just
trying to be honest and earnest and and
hopefully loving at the same time
that's all i can do is follow my own
interests
i know sean's going to jump in here in a
second let me just say real quick
kurt first of all you're doing a great
job
second of all don't forget everybody
loves a show okay there's a reason why
gladiator fights were so successful in
rome uh part of it was a control
mechanism to control the masses right
give them circus give them bread
human beings are for whatever reason
attracted to conflict
i don't know why uh it's it's something
that it may be deep in our dna uh maybe
it's part of the reptilian brain no pun
intended but you know something that for
whatever reason why we maybe watch we
watch monday night football because we
like that head-to-head competition or
boxing or whatever it is um
you know peop
conflict seems to be an innate part of
of the human species and
whether
we realize it or not even when we're
having an intellectual conversation like
this there are bound to be people that
want to see conflict whether it's
conflict of ideas or conflict of morals
or conflict of whatever principles
and and i think we see that i think we
see where we have my team versus your
team and you know
at the end of the gladiator fight thumbs
up or thumbs down yay or nay right and
um
you will see it in the academic and
scientific communities when people are
proposing theories and there's this
fierce debate where people take it
personally you see it on the floors of
congress when people are debating there
you see it
right here right now we're living
through this and and
we don't even realize we're engaged in
this type of activity because it's it's
it's so human
part of us to to to seek out this
conflict
when
you know people like sean have been
really helping people like me
try to step back you know from from that
because look my entire profession was
conflict right let's face it
government military intelligence your
job is to to out think the enemy and win
and let's face it the you know the the
war
the rule of war isn't to to create peace
the rule of war is to kill more enemies
and they kill you it's a very violent
brutal act and so it is part of what we
are as a species but let us recognize it
and let us control it rather than it
allowing it to control us would be my
my suggestion of course that's a topic
for a whole another discussion at some
point maybe down in the future but how
do we
how do we remove ourselves from this
this this
this
this self
generated conflict and rise above it
so sean what do you think
kurt i just wanted to say to you man
that i really feel something you said
because i heard it in your voice and i
saw it in your face
that people are telling you that you've
been that you've been um
that you have a responsibility now i
mean i want to break that down
we're saying you have you're holding a
responsibility
and i say no you haven't responsibility
comes first of all responsibility is
taken it's not given
it's taken
you've been offered opportunities
these people see that you've been
offered opportunities and they feel a
certain amount of
righteous jealousy towards you
and they're saying to you i'm not strong
enough to do this somehow you've won
this lottery so you have a
responsibility to carry out how i feel
in my stead
[ __ ]
you've been offered an opportunity your
heart tells you where you're going to
take responsibility
and then you give your whole heart to it
you give your whole acumen to it
nobody's superman nobody has everything
covered
you know what i mean so you have you
have to do what what's what's best for
you and you can't let you can't let
people tell you
you have a responsibility what is this
where is it is this is it on the counter
or is it is it hanging up with the coats
because i missed it when i walked in i
found my jeans my wallet but not my
responsibility
you know so pardon me for being kind of
smart out there but
but i see that you're under you're under
the same kind of strain that we are man
you you and and you may walk in front of
the mirror and say i have a
responsibility.
nobody else should be telling you you
have a responsibility besides your
spouse or your children
i agree with that and kurt listen it's
this is something that
you're probably going to face a lot more
than
than than most um
and this goes for anybody in your
audience too that's under something
similar okay so this advice isn't just
for for you kurt and as you know i don't
offer advice very often
um and it's advice i have to give myself
and sean has to give me and close
friends who might have to give me
constantly and my family
at the end of the day
you know
you're doing what you feel in your heart
is right
and um people are going to ascribe all
sorts of things and by the way there are
some bad people in this world believe me
i've i've met some of them on the wrong
end of a gun
there are truly some some bad people in
the world and they will
uh whether they're on the battlefield or
in cyberspace they will they will make
themselves known and they will do
whatever they can to hurt you
and this goes for people in your
audience who are experiencing the same
thing they're they know there are people
out there that want to hurt them
the question is why what are these
individuals out there that are trying to
hurt people what are what is their
deficiency what are they missing inside
that causes them to have so much hatred
towards other individuals is it jealousy
is it pride and ego is it a lack of of
someone maybe early on in their life
giving them the attention or or the
emotional fulfillment that they need or
the acknowledgement right who knows i
mean there's a lot of damaged units out
there
i try to not confuse the difference
between humans which i don't
particularly like and humanity i often
tell people you know it's i love
humanity it's humans i don't like very
much
there's an old saying by uh mel tormey
and this is probably why i have so many
dogs he said the more i get to know
people the more i like dogs um and i i
kind of i kind of understand that but at
the same time it's also not fair for me
to throw the baby out with a bath water
there's a lot of people right now that
are probably listening to to your show
that are generally just really good
people and they just want to know man
they just wanted to hey look i'm just
getting into this i'm just hearing this
for the first time is this [ __ ] real you
know that they just want to know that
um
so you know my guess my word of advice
to you curtis keep doing what you're
doing and and you know have the courage
to to face
um
the bad people
and and call them out for what they are
not in a mean way not to hurt them not
to do to them what they're trying to do
to you
but simply to to to
acknowledge that for what it is and and
then hopefully continue doing what you
do for the betterment of everybody else
who really just
wants answers they enjoy being with you
they enjoy spending their time with you
listening to you and your guests on the
show and they just want to learn
you got to remember to do it for them
and by the way i have to take my own
advice too so i'm not immune to that
there's days that i say you know screw
it these people aren't worth it they're
not worth it you know truth and freedom
and all that stuff they'll never evolve
to deserve it
and then i've got to call myself off the
ledge and say okay actually you know
what they do
and i'm just pissed off because a few
people that are are jerks happen to have
the loud voice when in reality you know
most of the most of the
of the majority is silent most of the
good people are silent it's it's the
it's the agitators that make most of the
noise
but in reality
most of the people aren't that way and
and i have to remind myself of that
for the people who are wondering hey i
thought this was a conversation about
ufos well in some ways this last hour
has been a meta conversation about ufos
because it's about the conversation
about ufos much like when the physics
community or some subset of the physics
community criticizes string theory
because it's taken the lion's share of
the money well that's not a science
conversation per se it's a meta
scientific conversation because it's
about well how we're going to divide
this up
and
there is plenty of conflict in this ufo
community but i know that you said
they're bad people i consider myself as
a part of that group and some people
would say well kurt you're ingenuous but
yeah but they don't see the malevolence
and the egotism and the covetousness and
the
and the insecurity of myself and i
wouldn't say that there yeah by people
you hear that you're you're facing it
there's a difference see you you you are
recognizing the fact that you're human
like the rest of us and we are all up
subject to to weakness that's what makes
us human it's okay
but acknowledge it don't you don't i
don't see you throwing stones as other
people i see you actually embracing that
part of you and saying look
i'm human and this is what i do and that
is that's humility and humbleness that's
not a bad trait that's a strength not a
weakness you just exhibited the fact
that you that you can heal from anything
you literally
the last thing in the world that a
narcissist can do
is question them themselves about
possibly being a narcissist
the moment you step in front of the
mirror and you go am i the cloudy day
that's dude that is such
a
a
an accomplishment
just considering hey am i the a-hole
here
yeah if you're considering it maybe you
were and that means maybe you can
overcome it and then but later on when
you get down the road and you find the
folks that can't find the mirror in the
house but are somehow always looking at
it
um
those folks are on a different plane
somehow i don't understand it but you're
you're not there man
you're considering yourself that and
don't stop don't be too hard on yourself
but bro
the fact that you would turn around that
quick and be like hey i'm a human being
just like these people i'm accusing of
being human
that's all it is
it's it's the grace we give each other
after that moment of self-awareness that
defines us
kurt that's a superpower the fact that
you can you can look at yourself in the
mirror
and say you know what
i don't like necessarily everything i
see
and you know
i i probably need to change some things
that that's that's not a fault brother
that that's a blessing and
you know i think we all we're all better
off for it when we can look in the
mirror and say you know what sometimes i
am weak sometimes i am selfish sometimes
i am petty sometimes i you know fill in
a blank whatever
issue it is um the problem are for those
individuals who can't do that whether
they're they they truly are sociopathic
individuals or they suffer from some
sort of personality disorder or
narcissism
um
that's the problem that because because
then there is no help because they they
will never be able to self-reflect and
change
when ultimately that is the journey for
all of us we are we're we're all brought
into an imperfect world
and and you know hopefully we leave this
world better than than we found it and
that's really you know in order to do
that you have to recognize that
hey
i'm not perfect you know and and i'm
going to make a lot of bonehead mistakes
i'm going to hold myself accountable i'm
not going to flog myself necessarily but
but i will hold myself accountable and
truly learn the lesson and when i make a
mistake i'll be damned if i make that
same mistake again i'm not going to say
i'm never going to make mistakes so i'm
going to make a mistake all the time i'm
human and i will that's just part of the
human condition
but learn from those men and don't
repeat the same mistake and have the
courage most importantly to stand in
front of the mirror and say you know
what i don't like that about you
that's that's a weakness you need to
change you need to work on it
um that that to me is a strength not not
a weakness at all if you have the
ability to do that curt and clearly
clearly you do i appreciate that i think
it's overly complimentary i i don't know
if i deserve all that but thank you so
much
and i also think that
you know this whole hating of humans i
know you said it glibly like hating
humans loving humanity seinfeld has a
comment about that too
i don't know if that's possible that's
something i used to believe too i don't
know if it's possible to dislike a
subset and like the whole i think that
somehow the view that one has for a tiny
object or a tiny subset
is somehow reflected in the whole and i
think that somehow i know this sounds so
hulky man but i think that somehow
maybe our purpose maybe this all sounds
so woo
go for it man go for it and peculiar but
maybe it's it's to meet hate with love
and to love even those that
you
at least initially despise even if
they're oppressing you you love your
oppressors and even if they're wrong in
you you love them i think that somehow
that's extremely integral
i think if you can do that that's
fantastic those are the life lessons
that some of the great people that have
walked this earth before us have tried
to preach
we don't always practice it you know i
will tell you i don't know if i agree
necessarily that in order to love the
whole you have to love the constituent
parts there are many examples in reality
where there are children that are born
out of a horrible situation whether it's
rape or something else and the child is
a wonderful loving child but the
situation that created the circumstances
that brought that child into this world
were less undesirable and you don't have
to love
you know
the the act of of of that in order to
love the end result of that
that's just my opinion you know there
there's i've witnessed in in within two
minutes of each other the best and worst
humanity has to offer
and there are elements of our species
that i really despise and by the way i'm
subject to the same thing so i'm not i'm
not go pointing my finger saying you
humanity i'm saying hey i don't know
yeah um
but i i i do think that
collectively you know for the reason why
i i can't answer for anybody else or
speak for anybody else the reason why i
do what i do
is because it's those two minutes of
beauty that i've seen the human species
capable of
we are capable of such hatred and
destruction towards each other but we
are also capable of such kindness and
beauty and that to me is worth saving
that is why i do what i do because
those moments those few precious moments
you know all of heaven all angels sing
when when a good act is done
uh and rejoice and it's it's for that
that is worth saving the species for
that's what makes us so wonderful
um unfortunately we are also our own
devils and and we we do things that are
very destructive towards each other and
ourselves
and that's just part of the human
condition i think that's
that's probably
normal in fact maybe that's one of the
reasons why we're here perhaps
is to learn to rise above it um you know
there are certainly certain religions
that feel that way that you know we're
going to continue coming back over and
over again until we finally learn our
lesson
um you know maybe that's the natural
order of things i i don't know but
i
i do think that we can it's okay to be
human but we need to recognize when when
we are doing evil towards each other and
and we have to
we have to be willing to hold each other
and ourselves accountable and that's
that's the life lesson
thank you all for
for coming out to this i appreciate it
it
took an interesting turn and i hope a
productive one
i think so there was a time in about a
month ago or so or two months ago when
on twitter i was realizing that there's
plenty of hate and i'm not saying i'm
immune from this hate like if people saw
what occurs in my mind i think people
will be extremely surprised
at the egotism and selfishness and so on
well there is there i wouldn't say
competing factions in the ufo content
creator community but there are
different beefs
and i thought you know it'd be great if
we could all why don't we all just put
that aside and just have
beer even though i'm drinking tea but
have beer
and
be on a collective zoom called just put
aside extend the olive branch
so while this conversation may seem like
it has nothing to do with ufos maybe
maybe but maybe it's an it's a more
important conversation because it
it deals with what gives birth to the
conversations about
ufos kurt how can you honestly have a
question and and a conversation and
answers
about
potentially one of the most existential
issues facing our species
if we don't even understand ourselves
how do you possibly expect
to
understand
someone or something else or another
species if we don't even understand how
we work
they are the same you if you want this
is why i kind of and i'll i'll
just share with you now the reason why i
said look when you ask your my number
one advice understanding ufos go hug
your kid and go hug your family
because that's where it starts
that's where it starts it doesn't start
reading a book it doesn't start with
having a conversation or podcast it
starts here starts here right now
reaching out and understanding
who you are as an individual and and and
what you are and what is meaningful in
life
that's where that journey begins it
doesn't start out there it starts in
here right here
that's how you have to make that journey
the very first step to understanding out
there is first understanding right here
and what's here
and and this is why i said what i did
without you know going into a lot of
detail earlier because it sounds kind of
kind of i know a little mushy but
but i mean it and sean will tell you how
many times have we over the years had
this conversation
there's there's no shortcut you can't
just all of a sudden have a shortcut and
boom now i understand you know the
secret to the universe you first have to
try to understand the secrets of
yourself that you've been keeping hidden
from yourself and others and only then
when you understand that will you be
able to even begin to ask the right
questions to understand what lies beyond
they're they're going to say oh i
thought you're about science and nuts
and bolts and evidence and all this that
and it's like but hold on a minute i can
tell you're not even here right now
you're not even present in the
conversation i don't mean you i mean the
you know the hypothetical person we're
talking to i'm like bro you're either
lost in the future or the past at every
moment either in fear of something that
hasn't incur occurred or in regret of
something that happened before trying to
figure out how not to go through that
pain again and try to avoid it you're
just on the treadmill and going
i'm not there anymore
you know and and it gives a different
perspective and it gives an idea of some
of the the larger ideas behind uap a
completely different
different vantage point
and i i think one way to
i know we're getting near the end of our
conversation but we do
some people ask me i say this this
phrase what's that mean and i'm like it
means what the two words mean we put
them together so
figure it out but consensus reality
is the reality that we're all sharing
our language our monetary systems our
our our decoration this the shapes of
our houses and our cars those are all
consensus reality we decided those
things look like that and we're going to
keep keep them looking like that and
things are going to look like this we're
going to talk this way and we're going
to do these things that could be flipped
upside down tomorrow and the human
animal would still survive it could all
be removed and the human animal would
develop a new way of communicating and a
new consensus reality and that consensus
reality at some point in our past was
about animalistic spirits
and and and
our connection to nature and now it's
very techno-based and very very very
self-aware and introspective
everyone's a guru now
everyone's a technological
uh uh you know a maniac they have all
the things that's a lousy word every
everyone is an engineer they have all of
these devices in their hands they can
collect all of this data now everyone
meditates
a thousand the world a thousand years
ago would not recognize this now they
would think we were all super people
and we all sit around still we're
laughing with each other because our
kids can't balance a checkbook
and
it's this is a large reality we
especially in this field we peel off
pieces of the of it that are way bigger
than we think they are
and we say i'm going to try to slap a
binary answer on this right now right
here and then
we can go chill out it's not that easy
your life lasts as long as your life
does your journey lasts as long as your
journey doesn't that may not be the nuts
and bolts answers some people want but
if you don't know who the hell you are
stop asking me who the hell they are
thank you both for coming out and for
spending so much time with me and the
3000
other people who are watching
it's an honor man
i know we went all over the place and i
love that we got
look you and when we talked beforehand i
told you whatever it is we'll get
through it
and it's not that we were anticipating
conflict but it was we knew that there
had been some you know there's been
static in the past and and we weren't
going to let you down because we weren't
going to give you easy answers you know
what i mean we were going to we're going
to give you the real folks that's what
we talked about coming out doing they
letting our hair down being real so i
appreciate you keep doing this
you know but we all have to learn from
the conversation we just have
thanks man yeah kurt i i agree thank you
always honor and privilege to be here
thank you for humility thank you for
your honesty um you know
we we we all we all
suffer privately sometimes with with
these demons and it's called it's called
uh
it's called humanity man we this is what
this is the situation we're in
um
let's just recognize and try to help
each other out of the ditch right
whenever one of us falls into the ditch
don't throw stones try to help the
person now come on out here let me give
you a helping hand you know
um and i think that's that's part of the
lesson of the journey and you know i
know you probably want to spend the last
hour talking about ufos but
in reality you know time has probably
come for us to have an honest
conversation about ourselves
you know in order to continue that
conversation about about ufos and and i
i want to applaud you for doing this i'm
not sure we've really had a chance to
ever do this before
um on any type of podcast and i want to
thank your audience for those out there
that are that are truly interested and
have been patient
with us thank you so much thank you for
letting us kind of
go off on a bit of a tangent if you will
uh or a detour um but i think it's
helpful for the conversation so we all
understand where we're coming from we
all understand understand each other uh
a little bit better and uh and then
maybe we get better at sharing ideas you
know with each other instead of um you
know sharing insults
okay i'll speak for another couple
minutes and answer any audience
questions
um i see todd trollbridge you had a
comment which said thanks kurt lou and
sean appreciate your time and effort
despite the challenges of having a
rational grounded conversation of this
subject area
i will make sure
that they see that
beer bottle gate that's hilarious
that's said by machiavelli too
dirty teaspoon wants to know if i can
invite richard dolan i have and here you
go
that's the url
joshua wants to know kurt do you feel
your foray into this topic has been a
net positive word negative i think
on the surface it's been a net negative
maybe it's been a net positive or will
become a net positive for myself
i hope that is a net positive for others
part of me taking a while before coming
back to this topic was me assessing that
but it's i'm not saying it's altruistic
it's mainly selfish i was assessing it
for myself
so kepster
asks kurt what did you learn from this
interview that they didn't already talk
about
well
generally i find that
most of the time watching anything on
ufos
any content on ufos doesn't provide me
with what's new although that's a bit
false because i'm so fresh i'm green in
this subject that there's bound to be
one two three pieces that are foreign to
me at the time
but much of the
learning at least for myself
doesn't come from what happened in the
moment but rather me thinking about the
content weeks later and then also
conversing with others much like a movie
when i watch a movie
it's a strange question to ask what did
i learn from the movie much of it comes
from weeks later and hearing what other
people think
and then also conversing with others and
mulling over my own thoughts
so it's not clear to me what is the
content is the content here or is the
content what occurs over the course of
days and months later someone wants to
know is gary nolan coming onto the show
yes
in early april i haven't announced the
specific date yet
pious interview will be march 27th
someone wants to know when am i getting
stephen greer on i've asked him or his
people
each month for the past six months or so
and they've said no each time
maybe even longer than six months justin
forder says thanks kurt look after
yourself thank you i'm trying
yes i'm trying
also now may be a great time to let you
know that there's a link to the patreon
in the description if you'd like to
support this podcast as the patrons and
the sponsors are the only reasons that
i'm able to do this full time i rely
pretty much exclusively on their support
and only do so if you feel like you have
the means there's no obligation at all
currently there's no special incentive
for being a patron such as a mug or some
ad-free experience nothing like that and
this is the way i'd like to keep it so
that you're not being persuaded to join
for any reason other than simply
supporting the podcast and also by the
way the comments that i mentioned about
people saying you are responsible for so
and so that happens from like five
people out of tens of thousands of
people it's just that there's this
negativity bias where i like i'm a i'm a
member of the human i'm a member of
humans and humans have this
there's this negativity bias where one
focuses overly on the anxiety provoking
okay well
thank you all i appreciate it
and take care
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you